So, moin Leute.
Exzellent.
Oh, ich hab meinen Tee vergessen.
Wo ist der Tee?
So, jetzt hab ich auch meinen Tee am Start.
Auf geht's.
Alfred, danke schön für den Pog-Sub.
Massive Pog.
So.
Let's go.
Ja, Leute.
Oh, es geht.
Soll ich euch mal sagen, was extremely nice ist?
Nice.
Ich hab erfahren, dass wir eine Regelung
auf der Arbeit haben, was Rufbereitschaft
angeht. No Limit.
Dankeschön für den Sub. Und zwar,
haltet euch mal fest, das ist eigentlich eine richtig geile Regelung.
Man muss aber davon wissen, weil
ansonsten trägt man vielleicht
Mist ein. Und zwar,
wenn jemand
Rufbereitschaft beantragt
und die nicht absagt
rechtzeitig,
also, nee, das muss ich anders,
ihr müsst das anders sagen,
dass ihr versteht, was ich meine. Also,
stellt euch vor, irgendjemand beantragt, ey, wir brauchen
zwei Leute oder einen am Wochenende
von
keine Ahnung, hier von
Freitagabend bis Montagsmorgens, also hier
16. oder 17. der Wochenende. So, wird beantragt,
derjenige stimmt zu,
wird genehmigt
und
jetzt sagen die hier,
dass sie das doch
nicht brauchen. Dann ist das
zu kurz zum
Absagen. Das heißt,
die können das zwar absagen,
aber du kriegst es trotzdem bezahlt,
weil es zu kurzfristig abgesagt
wurde. Und genau das gleiche
ist jetzt passiert. Die haben
gesagt, sie wollen Rufbereitschaft
haben für Wartungsarbeiten
am Samstag und
dann noch den restlichen Samstag und
bis Sonntagabend
haben sie beantragt,
habe ich zugestimmt und
gestern nach den Wartungsarbeiten
haben sie geschrieben,
Rufbereitschaft wird nicht mehr benötigt.
Das heißt,
ich sitze jetzt hier,
verdiene Geld, habe aber gar keine
Rufbereitschaft,
weil es zu kurzfristig ist, es abzusagen.
Eigentlich ultra nice Regelung,
oder?
Ja.
No limit, danke schön, danke schön
für den Sub. Eigentlich ultra nice
Regelung. Ich weiß nicht, wer sich das
ausgedacht hat, aber ich finde das
extremely
pog, weil
es ist ja auch nur fair, wenn man sich das mal
genau überlegt. Weil stell dir mal vor,
du hast
jetzt an dem Wochenende irgendwas abgesagt,
also da innerhalb von kurzer Zeit am
Rechner sein kannst und dann erzählen
sie dir Samstag, ach nee, jetzt Sonntag,
wo du dir eigentlich nichts vorgenommen
hast, kannst du doch alles machen, aber
kannst du dann gar nicht mehr, weil das
ja, weil es eigentlich ist das nur fair,
wenn man sich das mal überlegt, aber ich
glaube, das ist eine Regelung, die wenige
Läden haben. Finde ich auch. Ich sage,
eigentlich ist es nur fair, aber ich
glaube, jetzt mal ernsthaft, wo ist das sonst noch so?
Habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ich finde, das ist eine super, super Geschichte.
Wer beauftragt das? Das ist unterschiedlich, wer das
beauftragt. Das können Projekte beauftragen, das können
andere Abteilungen beauftragen, das kann die eigene
Abteilung beauftragen bzw. Abteilungen sind es
eigentlich weniger. Das sind dann Teams aus anderen
Abteilungen, die das beauftragen können, Projekte
können, das ist eigene. Du kannst es sogar für
dich selbst beauftragen, wenn du denkst, das ist
wichtig, dass da jemand da ist am Wochenende und so.
Das muss dann.
Erst deinen Chef genehmigen, wenn dein Chef, also
musst du dann, wenn es total weird ist und du schreibst
quasi, ey, Alter, ich will Kohle verdienen am Wochenende,
gib mal her, dann sagt er, nee, machen wir nicht.
Also du musst das, dein Chef muss es genehmigen und
danach muss es sogar explizit noch mal vom Betriebsrat
genehmigt werden, dass du am Wochenende was machen
darfst. Also sie sind da super korrekt, was aber auch
gut ist. Best Game Ever, yes, Best Game Ever, best game
ever. Bravo Remitz. Aber eigentlich ist das eine super
Regelung, ja. Thanks for your subscription. Ja, aber
aber ist ja auch gut so, dass das nicht geht. Also ich
finde das, ich finde das nur fair. Ich finde das
eigentlich nur fair. Ach ja, ich wollte, ich wollte euch
noch was zeigen. Ich glaube, ich habe mein Fahrrad ein
bisschen geschrottet, nicht wirklich geschrottet, nicht
wirklich geschrottet und zwar
ich habe ein bisschen dran rumgeschraubt und ich glaube
ich habe meinen, tja, wie nennt man das? Cage verbogen.
Gibt es, gibt es glücklicherweise für ein paar
Euro zum Nachkaufen. Ja, aber aber ihr kennt mich, ich kann,
ist das noch von dem, das, was? Ist das noch das vom
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das vom Umfall war,
hier, das ist das Bike vom Unfall und jetzt habe ich das
gleiche mit zweimal elf. Allein einziger Grund, warum ich
das mit zweimal elf habe, ist, weil es einmal elf nicht zum
liefern gab und ich ja eigentlich einmal zwölf wollte,
aber das gibt es noch nicht. Also, ja, was willst du machen?
Ja, machst du nix. TVH-Verhandlung. Ähm,
das habe ich noch, das habe ich noch nicht gehört, aber
inwieweit betrifft mich das? Das ist öffentlicher Dienst.
Tarifvertrag. Ich weiß nicht, wofür das steht, ehrlich
gesagt. Wofür steht TVH? Öffentlicher Dienst. Keine
Ahnung. TVH. Ich war, ich, Entgelt hier. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ach so, ne, Moment. Moment, moment. Was ist TVH? Dann, dann
habe ich mich, dann habe ich. Was ist TVH? Öffentlicher Dienst.
Info? Weißt du? Tarifvertrag für
den Öffentlichen Dienst des Landes Hessen. TVH. Ach das steht
für Hessen. Ach so, äh, inwieweit betrifft mich das
jetzt? Also, ist das irgendwie relevant für uns? Das betrifft,
Es betrifft weder Zugpersonal noch Buspersonal noch sonst was, oder?
Oder sagst du einfach nur so für Leute, die es betrifft?
Übrigens, was sagt eigentlich Bahnstreik?
Wie sieht es da eigentlich wieder aus?
Deutsche Bahn und GDH verhandeln wieder.
Vorerst kein Streik.
Nice.
Jetzt verdirbt Wieselski die Osterferien.
Zeit für neues Streikrecht.
Tja, es wird mal Zeit.
Soll ich euch mal sagen, wofür es Zeit wird?
Es wird mal Zeit, die Bahn wieder zu einem zuverlässigen Infrastrukturanbietenden Unternehmen zu machen.
Nicht zu dem Scheißhaufen, den sie gerade ist.
Was unter anderem gescheite Bezahlung für die Leute einschließt.
Plus mehr Leute.
Plus mehr Schienen.
Plus mehr Züge.
Plus mehr Personal insgesamt.
Plus, weil die Kohle ordentlich ausgeben und besser an den richtigen Stellen dahin.
Das ist ein absoluter Schrotthaufen, die Bahn.
Plus weniger Vorstand meinetwegen.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, ich brauche gar nicht weniger Vorstand.
Wenn die ihren Job gut machen, soll mir das recht sein.
Die können auch alle fett verdienen, das ist okay.
Ich muss ja dazu sagen, ne.
Es sind in letzter Zeit so viele Diskussionen immer, zu hohe Gehälter für Manager, zu hohe Gehälter für Vorstände.
Ja, sei es jetzt bei der Bahn, bei der Telekom, beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk und sowas.
Und ich denke mir immer so, ey, wisst ihr was?
Eigentlich ist das überhaupt nicht so.
Gar nicht das Problem, was ich mit dem ganzen Kram habe.
Dass die Chefs dort, die Oberstleute halt auch viel verdienen.
Das ist zwar, man könnte sagen, ein bisschen unverhältnismäßig zu dem, was der Rest verdient.
Also wenn du das mal so gesamt in den Deutschen anguckst, okay.
Aber ich sage, hey, das ist doch quasi die höchste Karrierestufe, die du da haben kannst.
Das ist okay.
Das Problem ist, dass die anscheinend für ihr Geld nur Scheiße machen.
Und keinerlei Konsequenzen fürchten müssen.
Was ja oftmals bei...
Sagen wir mal, normalen Unternehmen nicht der Fall ist.
Wenn du es da zu krass verkackst als Chef, dann fliegst du halt auch raus.
Aber dort, gerade bei der Bahn, das ist vollkommen egal.
Die haben die krasseste Fehlertoleranz ever anscheinend.
Also zumindest auf Vorstands- und auf Chefebene.
Die können jahrelang Scheiße bauen.
Und ihre...
Ich muss sich das mal vorstellen.
Die Bahn schafft es nicht, ihre selbstgestellten Ziele, die eh schon viel zu niedrig sind,
die sie selbst erheben können, die sie selbst auswerten können, nichts einzuhalten.
Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich.
Ihr könnt Gift draufnehmen.
Wenn ich mir ausdenken darf, was ich einhalten soll, die Erhebung dazu selbst machen kann, ja,
und das ganze Verfahren selbst bestimmen kann, dann halte ich wenigstens die Zahl der Formhalber am Ende ein.
Aber noch nicht mal das schaffen sie.
Obwohl da schon getrickst wird, erst Fakt, so nach dem Motto, wir lassen den Zug umdrehen, weil er zu spät ist,
dass er aus der Statistik rausfällt.
Weil mathematisch ist es ja nicht berechenbar, wenn ein Zug nicht kommt.
Wie viel Verspätung der hat.
Das sagt ja die Bahn.
Die Bahn sagt das ja wirklich.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Die Bahn sagt, wenn der Zug nicht kommt, dann ist das keine Verspätung, weil das ist ja quasi unendliche Verspätung.
Und damit kann man nicht rechnen.
Ich meine, es gibt dazu wahrscheinlich 100 naheliegende Lösungen, wie man das fixen kann.
Ja, man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, okay, dann deckelt man das.
Halt, sagen wir halt, okay, eine Stunde Verspätung hat er dann.
Oder sagen wir, okay, vielleicht rechnen wir, bis der nächste Zug auf dieser Linie kommt, der den gleichen Weg fährt,
bis dahin ist Verspätung, ja, oder irgendwas pauschal, irgendwas, ja.
Aber einfach zu sagen, man lässt es ganz raus.
Und dann kommt ja der Witz.
Man lässt nicht nur die Verspätung raus, man lässt ja auch quasi die Haltestellen raus.
Das wird ja dann gar nicht mitgerechnet.
Das heißt, sie sieht dann viel.
Und selbst mit diesem ganzen Schöngespräch.
Ich rechne, selbst dann halten sie ihre eigenen Zeilen nicht ein.
Es ist halt komplett, komplett für den Arsch.
Und bei der ganzen, bei der ganzen Streikgeschichte von der Bahn oder von öffentlichem Nahverkehr in Frankfurt.
Hier, Frankfurt war ja auch, bin jetzt gelandet, wollte ich überhaupt nicht hin.
Frankfurt VGF heißen die, ja.
Die haben ja auch letztens gestreikt.
Gestreikt wird nicht zum Spaß, ja.
Ich habe damit überhaupt kein Problem.
Dass sie streiken.
Obwohl ich immer am Flamen bin.
Ich habe ein Problem damit, dass unsere Infrastruktur nicht funktioniert.
Und das mein persönliches, tägliches Leben beeinflusst.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, dass die Bahn oder die VGF oder sowas streikt.
Wenn, wenn ich, wenn mich heute jemand fragen würde, ja.
Möchten sie es verbieten, dass Bahn und VGF streiken darf.
Dann würde ich, also, also, was heißt, wenn man jetzt abstimmen könnte, ja.
Wollen sie dafür abstimmen?
Dass sie nicht streiken dürfen.
Dann würde ich sagen, nein. Würde ich nicht.
Ich, ich, ich, die sollen ihr Recht dazu wahrnehmen dürfen, wie alle anderen.
Trotzdem kann ich natürlich die Auswirkungen und die unver-, unver-, nicht verfügbare und unzuverlässige Infrastruktur, die mich in meinem täglichen Leben behindert, scheiße finden.
Ja.
Und dementsprechend auch ein bisschen meinen Wut da drüber auslassen.
Es ist ja eh normal, dass du heute in Social Media dich wegen jedem Scheiß aufregst.
Da kann man sich auch mal wegen etwas ordentlichem aufregen.
Und das sind zwei Sachen.
Ich finde, die, die, die muss man.
Ja.
Die, die muss man nicht gleichermaßen sehen.
Also, man kann durchaus es okay finden, dass die streiken dürfen.
Und auch dafür sein, dass die gefälligst weiter dürfen.
Trotzdem kann man die Auswirkungen scheiße finden.
Deshalb, ich lese dann immer so Dinge wie so, ja, eh, volle Solidarität und, und, eh, jetzt meckert man nicht hier, die kämpfen auch für uns und solche Sachen.
Ja, schön, sollen sie machen?
Für mich nicht.
Also, ich finde es nach wie vor scheiße.
Das ist, dass ich nicht fahren kann.
Ich finde es gut, dass sie das dürfen.
Aber ich finde es scheiße, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Ich finde es übrigens auch genauso scheiße, dass es nicht funktioniert, wenn die Bahn nicht streikt.
Der Witz ist ja, ist euch mal aufgefallen und das ist jetzt, wie sagt man so schön, wie nennt sich das?
Anekdotische Evidenz.
Also, ist euch mal aufgefallen oder vielleicht ist euch auch so aufgefallen, dass wenn die Bahn streikt, dass die Züge, die dann fahren, deutlich pünktlicher sind.
Weil es halt wahrscheinlich so wenig ist.
Und so, so viel weniger los ist, dass die, die fahren, dann weniger Probleme haben.
Was ja schon auf strukturelle Probleme schließen lässt in der Infrastruktur.
Außerdem, das, außerdem, ich hab's ja letztens schon auf Twitter geschrieben.
Es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied, ob sie streiken oder nicht.
Weil die Bahn kommt in beiden Fällen nicht pünktlich.
Nur bei dem einen mit Ankündigung.
Bei dem anderen halt.
Bei dem anderen halt einfach so.
Ich geh auch mal von aus, dann hätten wir die Probleme nicht.
Wobei, die Probleme kommen ja unter anderem gerade bei der Bahn daher, dass man die letzten Jahre über, oder letzten, weiß ich nicht wie lang das ist, 20, 15, 20, 20 Jahre.
Letzten 20 Jahre versucht hat, sowas wie möglichst bling-bling auszusehen, ohne bling-bling zu sein.
Damit man eventuell Aktien für die Bahn gut verkaufen kann.
Was ja, wozu es ja dann nie gekommen ist.
Ja, hab ich doch gerade, hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Ja, genau.
Oder 30 Jahre.
Das, das sieht man oftmals bei irgendwelchen Unternehmen, die aufgekauft werden.
Oder super, von irgendeinem Investor super krasse Finanzspritze bekommen haben, gegen irgendwie ein Mitspracherecht, ja.
Da hast du dann auch so Dinger, dass das, was auf den ersten Blick super viel Geld kostet.
Und vielleicht auch ein paar Jahre ohne funktioniert, dass das rausgeschmissen wird.
Zum Beispiel, stell dir vor, du hast 1000 Leute, du hast super gepflegte Züge, du hast genug Strecken und alles.
So, du würdest jetzt, du würdest jetzt ein Drittel der Leute rausschmeißen.
Du würdest deine Züge ab dann nicht mal warten, deine Strecke nicht mal richtig warten und Strecken stilllegen.
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass du in den nächsten 5 Jahren Aktien verkaufen möchtest.
Ist natürlich super, weil auf dem Papier sieht es natürlich toll aus.
Du hast auf einmal viel mehr Geld in der Tasche und du hast die Auswirkung davon nicht unmittelbar, bekommst du nicht unmittelbar zu spüren.
Ja, dass du ins, dass du die Zugwartung einstellst, die Schienenwartung einstellst, die Strecken stilllegst, was auch immer.
Das merkst du erst in 5 bis 10 Jahren und dann halt immer mehr.
Aber die, diese 5 Jahre, bis, bis das anfängt immer, immer, immer Painschampinger zu werden.
Sehen deine Zahlen einfach richtig geil aus.
Und das ist das, was die bei der Bahn gemacht haben.
Und das ist, das ist eigentlich, es ist eigentlich gar nicht, ich hab letztens ein Interview gelesen von einem.
Der hat gesagt, dass das eigentlich, also so wie sie es jetzt machen und, und strukturell, infrastrukturmäßig gar nicht zu fixen ist die Bahn.
Weil so viele Strecken auch abgebaut wurden, auf denen sich heute eben keine Bahnstrecke mehr befindet.
Also sprich, die wurden nicht einfach nur stillgelegt.
Auf den Strecken steht heute was anderes.
Da ist jetzt irgendwie ne Sportanlage oder ein paar Häuser oder was auch immer.
Da kannst du gar nicht einfach irgendwelche Bahnstrecken wieder hinstellen.
Die Kennzahlen sind ja nicht mal, ja jetzt nicht, jetzt nicht!
Jetzt sind wir auch in der Phase, wo man die Auswirkungen von wir machen keine Wartung, wir legen, jetzt spürt man die Auswirkungen, ja dass die jetzt nicht mehr gut sind wird klar.
Wir legen jetzt, jetzt spürt man die Auswirkungen, ja dass die jetzt nicht mehr gut sind wird klar.
Ich glaube das kann dochלה gutciteln, oder?
Aber die ersten paar Jahre, als man damit angefangen hat, waren die mit Sicherheit besser denn je.
Die Bahn ist einfach ein richtiger Drecksladen.
Ich habe wirklich gegen wenige, also ich habe gegen kaum jemand was.
Also schon mal gar nicht persönlich.
Außer die Leute gehen mir halt auch persönlich auf den Sack.
Ich habe eigentlich gegen kaum jemand wirklich jetzt so, dass ich sagen würde, ich hasse die oder so.
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die mag ich nicht.
Die haben die aber meistens auch verdient.
Aber die meisten Sachen sind mir eigentlich ziemlich egal, solange die mich nicht persönlich großartig betreffen.
Ich habe dann auch bei wenigen Sachen irgendwie den großen Drang dazu, mich auf Twitter moralisch aufzuspielen von irgendwelchen Dingern, die mich persönlich hier nicht interessieren.
Das meiste ist mir eigentlich egal.
Aber die Bahn nicht.
Wenn es eine Sache gibt, die ich wirklich abgrundtief hasse, dann ist es die Bahn.
Und die Bahn als Ganzes.
Nicht den Typ, der irgendwie als Zugbegleiter eh schon gestresst ist.
Nicht mal direkt, nicht mal direkt das Management der Bahn, wobei die das hauptsächliche Problem sind.
Weil die setzen ja auch eine Marschrichtung um, die vorgegeben wurde.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute im Bahnmanagement sonderlich fähig sind.
Was man ja auch sieht, dass die alle nicht, oder doch, ich glaube der aktuelle Bahnchef kommt sogar selbst aus dem Unternehmen.
Allerdings war der irgendwie irgendwie bewegt.
Ich glaube, er hat die ganze Zeit nur ein LWL-Controller oder so bis dahin.
Aber davor, die ganzen Leute bei der Bahn, die kamen ja zum größten Teil alle, glaube ich aus der Automobilindustrie.
Oder ehemalige Politik.
Also die anderen von der Bahn habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Also wenn es eine Sache gibt, die ich echt abgrundtief hasse, dann ist es die Bahn.
Und die tun auch alles dafür, dass es so bleibt.
Ja.
Kleiner, kleiner Rant am Rande.
Ja, ne.
Ich mein...
Das einzige...
Wisst ihr...
Das einzig Gute, was die letzten Jahre...
Jahre über auf die Reihe bekommen,
was sie dort auf die Reihe bekommen haben, ist das 49-Euro-Ticket.
Und wie lange
das 49-Euro-Ticket noch 49-Euro-Ticket
sein wird,
weiß man ja auch nicht.
Gibt's grad keine News zu.
Ja, 2023,
Keckel, Alter.
Ja.
Das ist das einzig Gute, was sie die letzten Jahre
da über hinbekommen haben.
Ich finde, es gab ja mal,
wie war das letztes Jahr, 9-Euro-Ticket
oder sowas, gell? Gab's nicht
letztes Jahr so ein 9-Euro-Ticket
für zwei Monate? Ich finde, das hätte gar nicht
sein gemusst. Das 49-Euro-Ticket
ist das erste Mal, wo ich wirklich sage,
hey, damit hat man eine riesen
Verbesserung und auch ein riesen Bürokratie.
Bürokratische Sachen gefixt.
Weil eines der verwirrendsten
Dinger, wenn jemand mit der Bahn in Deutschland
fährt, ist, diese ganze
Verkehrsverbund-Kacke.
Du hast hier in Frankfurt den RMV
in Köln hast du den
in Frankfurt hast du VGF
in Köln hast du irgendwas
KVF oder so
KVG oder irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung oder KVB
und in Hamburg
hast du wieder was anderes.
Dann hast du in Bayern was anderes
wie in Hessen und es ist so
super weird. In Bayern hatten sie
schon die ganze Zeit ganz gut. In Bayern gab's
so ein Bayern-Ticket. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das in Hessen
auch gab.
In Bayern bin ich ein paar Mal gefahren
mit dem Bayern-Ticket. Das war dann auch so
konzentriert. Aber
das war so
ultra-undurchsichtig, verwirrend.
Das hat niemand gecheckt.
Dann hast du fünf Apps
gebraucht.
Wenn du da unterwegs warst, um
dir das kaufen zu können. Und ich weiß noch,
ich weiß noch, als ich das
letzte Mal auf der Gamescom war,
da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, weißt du was?
Heute kaufst du dir
einfach mal dein Wochenticket
dort übers Handy.
Und da hab ich
mir diese, was ist das, KVB-App?
Ja. Egal, die haben
irgendeine komische App für...
So. Und da wollte ich da drin
ein Ticket kaufen. Da ging das nicht.
Und da musste ich erst ein Account erstellen.
Und danach hätte ich
Postident machen sollen.
Fucking Postident!
Ich habe im Zug
gesessen nach Köln, Mann. Ich kann kein
Postident machen, dass ich mir
ein Ticket kaufen kann über die App.
Okay, ich gebe zu,
das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja zumindest Postident
nicht mehr über Post. Das heißt dann
ID. Ne, wie heißt denn das heute?
PostID heißt das, glaube ich, gell?
Wo du dann
vorm Handy rumhüpfen musst.
Naja,
zumindest...
Konntest du das vergessen? Dann bin ich wieder zum Automatort.
Und die Story mit
Köln und diesem Ticket habe ich euch
jetzt ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, Recycle-Story.
Aber nur nochmal, um das zu untermausen.
Unter Mauern, was das
für ein Shit ist mit diesen Verkehrsverbünden.
Ich gehe in Köln am Hauptbahnhof
an den Automat, hole mir ein
Wochenticket. Es kommt ein Ticket raus.
Da unten
und auf dem Ticket steht unten drunter
nur gültig mit
KVB-ID oder irgendwie
sowas. Da denke ich mir so,
hä? Was?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was
ihr wollt.
Und da sind wir in diese Informationszentrale
vom KVB. Da waren Felix und ich,
im Köln Hauptbahnhof,
in dieses KVB-Büro und haben das da gezeigt.
Und
da meinte die,
ja,
das ist irgendwie für
Monatstickets, wenn man die
personalisiert hat.
Ja, aber das ist vom Automat.
Meinte die, ja, lassen Sie es einfach
leer.
Oh Mann, haben die da die falschen
Papiere eingelegt? Oder wie
dumm kann man das eigentlich machen?
Da
muss ich sagen, da fand ich das in München
nicht schlecht. Weißt du, nicht so oft
in München. Aber da,
wo ich in München war, da konntest du dir einfach so ein
Münchenticket ziehen, an jedem random
Automat und konntest dann mit allem fahren, wo du
Bock hattest. Ja.
Deswegen,
deswegen finde ich das 49-Euro-Ticket
super. Da musst du dir um den ganzen Shit keine
Gedanken machen. Was? Ein Freund
hat eine Strafe in München in der Bahn bekommen, weil er das
Ticket nur gekauft hat und nicht einge... Was?
Äh, ja, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Das musst du entwerten, ne? Das
musst du da irgendwie reinstecken, irgendwo bei einmal.
Ja, also das kenne ich,
aber das in München fand ich das eigentlich ganz gut.
9 Euro zu 49 Euro,
ein Riesenunterschied für alle Bürgergeld-
Empfängerautos. Ja, das
stimmt. Das ist wohl,
das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Aber ich denke
einfach, dass die
Zusatzkosten sich bei 49
Euro noch ein bisschen mehr in Grenzen halten.
Das Ticket auch manche kaufen, die
das vielleicht gar nicht so sehr brauchen. Und, was
ich ja nicht schlecht finde,
also, 9, ob, das ist jetzt aber
für das, was ich jetzt sage, ist egal, ob
9 Euro oder 49 Euro, wobei mehr
49 Euro als 9 Euro.
Ich bin nicht dafür, dass man es kostenlos macht.
Es gibt ja immer noch die ganzen,
ähm, ja, sieht man ja öfter so,
öffentlicher Nahverkehr soll kostenlos
sein, alles. Vom Ansatz her
gut. In der Praxis, glaube ich,
ist es eine ganz blöde Idee, das komplett kostenlos
zu machen, weil
aus, aus, aus,
aus zwei Gründen.
Das erste ist der
Einkaufswagen-Effekt.
Also, ihr kennt
es ja, ihr müsst ja einen Euro
in den Einkaufswagen reinmachen.
Und seitdem man dort einen Euro in den Einkaufswagen
reinmachen muss, werden deutlich
weniger Einkaufswagen geklaut und beschädigt.
Weil die Leute gar irgendwie
psychologisch, fragt mich nicht, wie das genau
funktioniert, dadurch, dass sie dann einen Euro
reingesteckt haben, einen gewissen Wert
mit diesem Einkaufswagen verbinden.
Und,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass,
wenn es komplett
kostenlos in der Bahn ist,
der Wert
der, der, ja, der Bahn,
das, das, ja, des ganzen
Transports und
der Züge und so
geistig nicht mehr geschätzt wird
und dann noch mehr kaputt
gemacht wird, an Zügen
beschmiert wird, kaputt gemacht wird,
Polster zerschnitten wird, alles mögliche, weil das
gar kein Wertgefühl
mehr hat bei Leuten, so.
Das ist das Erste. Das Zweite ist aber, wenn es komplett
kostenlos ist, dass die ganzen
Penner aus Frankfurt
den ganzen Tag nur noch im Zug abhängen würden.
Und das ist jetzt
kein theoretisches Problem, das ist ein praktisches Problem,
das gibt es nämlich jetzt teilweise schon.
Aber jetzt werden die immer wieder rausgeschmissen,
weil, ja,
haben halt nichts, was sie berechtigt, da drin zu fahren.
Wenn das aber kostenlos wird und einfach
random jeder einsteigen kann,
dann könntest du quasi die ganzen
Züge, die
nahverkehrsmäßig in irgendwelchen Großstädten fahren,
gar nicht mehr normal benutzen.
Gerade U-Bahn, Straßenbahn,
S-Bahn
und AEs
kannst du knicken, ey.
Dann werden die ganzen Leute, die jetzt am Hauptbahnhof
drumherum abhängen, die würden dann im Zug
liegen.
Deswegen finde ich
9 Euro oder 49 Euro ist fast
egal, aber es muss was kosten.
Ich glaube, in Luxemburg
haben sie auch nicht so viel Großstädte mit
massig Assis und Pennern.
Oder,
oder aber
sie müssten
irgendwelche, ja, wie soll man sagen,
irgendwelche Regeln
erlassen, so nach dem Motto,
keine Gepäckmitnahme im Nahverkehr.
Ja, dann würden die ganzen Leute schon mal rausfallen,
weil die ihren Einkaufswagen
beziehungsweise ihre Gepäcksachen
nicht mitnehmen können, ihre Isomatte
und sowas, den Schlafsack.
Was könntest du
machen?
Oder du müsstest sagen, du musst ordentlich
angezogen sein, aber die Frage ist, was ist ordentlich
und da falle ich auch nicht immer drunter.
Also, am besten ist,
das kostet ein bisschen was und dann,
dann wird es das Problem nicht geben.
Ob jetzt 9 Euro oder 49, ist da glaube ich
relativ egal.
Ja, das ist auch, und du kannst dir sicher sein,
das ist auch ein guter, weiterer guter Punkt,
ein 49-Euro-Ticket, du kannst dir sicher sein,
du hast das Handy dabei, du hast das Ticket dabei.
Übrigens, ich wurde bisher erst einmal
kontrolliert und wollte einen Ausweis
von mir sehen. Habe ich ihm gesagt,
ich habe keinen Ausweis dabei,
ich habe nur eine Eintrittskarte
für
meinen Arbeitgeber hier
um den Hals hängen, habe ihm das gezeigt.
Meinte er, ja, aber das ist ja eigentlich nur gültig
mit einem Ausweis.
Habe ich gesagt, ja,
okay.
Hat er gemeint, ja, aber nächstes Mal und ist weitergegangen.
Plottwist
der ganzen Sache ist, ich hatte
den Ausweis im Rucksack, war aber bloß zu faul,
ihn rauszuholen. Also, die
interessiert das überhaupt nicht.
Ach übrigens, habt ihr gesehen, der DB
Streckenagent,
falls das Ding jemand benutzt,
der wird eingestellt,
was,
äußerst, achso,
ich verstehe eh schon nicht, warum es tausend verschiedene
Bahn-Apps braucht. Ja, es gibt den DB Navigator,
den DB Navigator Next,
den DB Streckenagent, es gibt fünf verschiedene
Bahn-Apps. Der Streckenagent
war aber der Beste,
weil der Streckenagent
hatte eine ordentliche History,
der Streckenagent hatte Notifications,
wenn Züge ausfallen
und der Streckenagent hatte
als einzige Bahn-App
eine sinnvolle Update, also
Regierungsfunktion und eine sinnvolle
minutengenaue Anzeige von
Verspätung. Und der Streckenagent
wird eingestellt.
Ob der Streckenagent
jetzt mit allen Funktionen im Navigator
bereitgestellt wird,
weiß ich nicht. Es soll eine neue App geben,
die den Streckenagent ablöst,
aber diese App gibt es noch nicht.
Die hätten den Strecken-Champ nennen müssen, ja.
Aber Leute, wenn ihr
einfach nur wissen wollt, ob eure Züge
Verspätung haben, die beste Seite ist
Bahn.expert.
Guckt, da suchst du jetzt hier zum Beispiel
Hanau Hauptbahnhof.
Die Seite ist übrigens mega gut
und schnell gemacht. Sehr nice.
Gibt's übrigens einen
nicen Vortrag
auf Youtube
von dem Typ, der die Seite
gebaut hat,
wie er das gemacht hat und wie
wir das Abfragesystem der Bahn
ist. Ja, da kann man dann
zum Beispiel hier sagen, okay, gucken wir uns
den Zug an, da sieht man hier, aha,
die Wagen und man sieht hier auch
die Verspätung und
die Seite ist sehr clever.
Die Seite greift
nicht einfach nur auf die offizielle Bahn
API zu, sondern
auf alle Verkehrsverbünde,
also
auf alle Verkehrsverbund APIs
auf der Strecke des
ganzen Zuges. Also dieser Zug,
der fährt hier von Frankfurt nach
oder hier von Wächtersbach
Hanau nach Frankfurt.
Wächtersbach
ist noch Hessen, ja. Es gibt
also, nehmen wir den hier.
Ja, hier schön. Also, der fährt
von Bayern, der fährt von Bayern
nach Hessen.
Im Prinzip der Zug hier, ja.
Und was
der Typ jetzt gemacht hat ist,
der zapft die offizielle Bahn API
an, der zapft aber auch die
API vom RMV an und er zapft
die API an vom Bayerischen
Verkehrsverbund und dann
overlayt er das und guckt
wo die meiste
Verspätung quasi
drinnen steht. Weil ihm ist aufgefallen,
dass manche Züge pünktlich
drinnen stehen in der Bahn-App, aber
beispielsweise in der
RMV-App für den Rhein-Main-Verkehrsverbund
schon mit Verspätung drinnen.
Das heißt, er fragt die ganzen APIs ab,
durch die der Zug
geht, also durch die Region, wo der Zug geht,
overlayt das und dann kriegt
man, das ist, die Seite ist so gut,
dass ich gehört habe,
dass die sogar intern von Bahnmitarbeitern
benutzt wird zum Checken, weil die besser ist
als ihre eigene.
Das sagt alles. Hat jemand
einen Link zum, ähm,
wie hieß denn, wie hieß
denn diese Seite ursprünglich, die hieß
die hieß Maru, Bahn,
Marudor oder so hieß die
ursprünglich, ja.
Und da gibt es einen Vortrag, hier.
Bahn-API-Chaos, ja.
Vor vier Jahren.
Findet man in Hamburg.
Ja. Das ist
der Vortrag hier. Da hat er anscheinend mehrere Vorträge,
in erster Krisel. Der hat, das ist
der Ursprungsbeitrag, den ich mal gesehen habe, aber
da gibt es noch mehr dazu.
Also hier, das ist der Typ von
der Seite. Dafür
ist die Seite super schnell. Ich finde, die ist
gut gemacht.
Das ist vielleicht nicht
die Vollendung des Frontend-Designs,
aber da gibt es schlimmeres.
So, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, ich mach mal meine
VM an und update.
Dann schauen wir mal auf YouTube rein. Leute,
ratet mal,
was es heute zu essen gibt bei mir nachher.
Letzte Woche gab es Nudeln
mit Bolognese.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nein! Falsch!
Ha! Tibated!
Tomatensauce. Nein, gibt es auch nicht.
Es gibt heute
ganz was anderes. Da könnt ihr überhaupt nicht drauf
kommen, aber ich wusste, dass ihr wieder sagt Lachs.
Nein! Falsch! Es gibt heute ganz
was anderes, außer der Reihe,
weil das noch übrig ist von letzter Woche.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie das richtig heißt.
Es ist so Kartoffel mit
Pilz und Käse
Zeug drüber.
So eine Art Kartoffel-Auflauf ist
das, glaube ich.
Gratter.
Ja.
So was.
Das, was hot as fuck ist,
wenn man es isst.
Oder was
hot as fuck auf den Teller
kommt, wo man sich immer schön
verbrennt dran.
Warum ist der Download so langsam?
Das ist nicht Blazingly Fast.
Das ist PepoLag.
Wo habe ich denn das passende Emote für da?
So Leute, bevor wir Github
Ex... Ex... äh... nicht.
Github Trends gucken
und YouTube-Videos. Wir gucken uns,
habe ich mir vorgenommen, wir gucken uns jetzt
noch eine
Stellenanzeige an, die übrig geblieben ist vom letzten
Stellenanzeigen-Video, weil
sonst kriege ich die Dinger nie durch.
Wir müssen uns einmal pro Stream eine
davon angucken. Ich habe, glaube ich,
nämlich noch acht oder so offen. Die habe ich
nicht hin... habe ich nicht geschafft, mir das letzte
Mal anzugucken. Gucken wir uns eine
Viertelstunde an und dann machen
wir mit normalem Sonntagsprogramm weiter.
Warum ist das so langsam?
Was ist hier los? Anzeige.
Pac-Man in Rust umschreiben. Ich habe
schon, ich habe schon einen written in Rust...
Nee, nee, written in Go Package Manager.
Aber in was ist Pac-Man
selber eigentlich?
Programmiert. C?
Pac-Man is written
in the C-Programming language.
Ah, Giga-Chats am Start.
C-Programmers.
Gestern hat ein Pärchen drei
große Boxen Sushi vom Stand gekauft
für 25% vom Preis.
Wie für 25% vom Preis?
Warum kriegen die das so günstig?
Haben die da falsch dran, haben die das falsch
ausgeschildert,
preist, oder?
Ja stimmt, auf dem Handy funktioniert die gut.
Ach so, von
gestern, ja. Gut, wenn das gut gekühlt ist,
hätte ich das auch genommen.
Wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Mal gucken, ob ich was übersehen habe.
Falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe, schreibt's einfach nochmal.
Okay.
Ah, Chat.
Sekunde, ich muss checken,
was die Stongs machen.
Muss ja auch einmal sonntags überprüft
werden. Die Stongs...
Ah, fuck, Scalable hat's
schon mal wieder ausgelockt.
Noob-App, ey.
Alter!
Ho!
Alter, ey, die...
What the fuck?
Ah ne, diese Woche ging's sogar ein bisschen runter.
Diese Woche
ging's, diese Woche gingen die Stongs sogar
minimal runter.
Aber nicht viel.
Aber es ist, es ist, also, dieses Jahr
sind die Stongs, also eigentlich, eigentlich
seit Oktober,
November, seit November
sind, sind die Stongs richtig
krass gestiegen.
Seit jetzt innerhalb von einem Jahr plus
7.679
und 74 Cent.
Leise Zahl.
Also, das ist ja nur theoretisch.
Ja.
Das ist ja nur theoretisch, weil
ich hab's ja noch nicht verkauft.
Erst, wenn ich verkaufe, hab ich die Kohle.
Was ist jetzt los? Warum geht...
Wat?
Was ist das? Chatge?
Warum ist das kaputt?
Muss ich rebooten?
Moin.
Warum ist mein Package Manager kaputt?
Anzeige ist raus.
Das muss ich jetzt grad mal checken, ob das wirklich,
wirklich so ist.
Das wäre der Sack schlechthin.
Massive.
So, schauen wir mal.
Ob das wirklich kaputt ist
jetzt. Das wäre, wäre echt...
Painz Champ.
Was ist das?
Hier. Anzeige.
Lip
Alpen.
Achso. Warum ist das
broken? Schauen wir mal nach,
was da los ist.
Aha. Jay und Paaro broken.
Can't do anything with them.
Aha. Was ist da los?
This can be solved with a com...
Ah, ja. Okay, die haben irgendwas verkackt.
Okay, man muss das einmal umlinken
und danach geht das wieder.
Okay.
Man muss das einmal umlinken.
Und nach dem Upgrade gehe ich mal von außen
geht's dann wieder. Ja, guck hier, gibt auch,
gibt auch ein...
Upgrade und danach kann ich den Link wahrscheinlich wieder
entfernen. Was ein Scheiß, ey.
Arch, by the way.
Ich gehe davon aus, wenn man das upgradet, ist okay.
Arbeitet jemand regelmäßig
mit SQL-Anbangen als Anwendungsentwickler?
Haben das Thema gerade in der Ausbildung.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, es gibt kaum einen
Anwendungsentwickler, der nicht regelmäßig
was mit Datenbanken macht, oder?
Weil,
es gibt ja keine, wie soll man sagen,
keine andere sinnvolle Art
wirklich zum Persistieren
von Daten.
Na klar, es gibt so ein paar
Nischen-Sachen, ja, du kannst
irgendwelche Key-Value-Stores verwenden, du kannst
Sachen auf der Platte speichern, du kannst es
in einem Cache, aber eben der Regelwert persistiert
in der Datenbank. Ja, gut.
Okay, wer Microcontroller-only
Zeug macht, aber sag mal so, wer
erkennt Anwendungen und sowas entwickelt,
kommst du... Aber...
Postgres ist das Beste.
Das ist genau das Richtige, alles andere ist Shit.
Also nicht, dass es nicht funktionieren
würde, aber alles andere ist teuer
und man könnte sagen
schlechter, wobei ich das nicht einschätzen kann,
da bin ich zu Datenbank-Noob für.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, dass Oracle
und sowas ultra, also nicht nur
ultra, Oracle ist
unverschämt teuer, genauso wie
SAP.
Was witzig ist bei mir auf der Arbeit, wir
haben mindestens fünf verschiedene Datenbanken.
Wir haben MS... Leute, ich glaube,
ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, wir sind
der einzige Laden, muss ich euch mal fragen,
hat jemand von euch
MSSQL unter
Linux? Gibt es jemand, der
so, was so schisslich veranlagt
ist und den Shit verwendet?
In der Kombi?
Sonst löschen wir den Link mal.
Wer würde sowas... Ja, wir machen das.
Äh,
sudo rm
Link das auf das,
das da kann ich löschen.
Guck, jetzt funzt er immer noch.
Wer würde sowas... Also wir machen das.
Wir haben MSSQL unter Linux,
wir haben
Postgres,
wir haben Oracle,
wir haben SAP HANA,
wir haben IBM
DB2
und bestimmt noch mehr Zeug. Also bei
uns ist ultrakrasser Datenbank
Wildwuchs. Glücklicherweise habe ich
bei den meisten Sachen nichts zu tun. Ach so,
wir haben auch noch MongoDB irgendwo
und wahrscheinlich
MySQL auch noch irgendwas in der
Richtung, ja. Was ist der Vorteil
gegenüber MariaDB und MySQL? Also,
ich bin nicht der super krasse Datenbank
Checker. Das muss ich gleich dazu
sagen. Was ich persönlich an Postgres
nice finde, ist, dass Postgres so
vieles kann. Postgres kannst
du als ganz normale, relationale Datenbank
verwenden. Postgres kann
du als simplen Key-Value-Store
mit JSON-Support sogar verwenden.
Postgres kannst du
als Volltext-Suche verwenden, inklusive
Sub-String-Suche. Postgres
kannst du als Time-Series-Datenbank
verwenden und das allerwichtigste
ist, in Postgres kannst
du Doom spielen.
Wusstet ihr das, dass man in Postgres
Doom spielen kann?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Postgres Doom.
Gibt es dazu vielleicht ein Video?
Ever since...
Hier, Doom.
Man sieht zwar kaum was, aber
ich glaube, man erkennt
es, oder? Es ist Doom in Postgres.
Also, das sollte eigentlich
jetzt jeden überzeugt haben.
Ach ja, und es gibt sogar einen Package-Manager
für Postgres. Also, ich glaube,
es gibt kaum eine Datenbank, die so nice
viele Features hat wie Postgres und
die du für so viele verschiedene Sachen verwenden
kannst. Klar kannst du sagen, hey,
für einen Key-Value-Store, Cache,
sonst was
gibt es bessere Sachen. Für
NoSQL gibt es bessere Sachen. Für
Volltext-Suche gibt es bessere Sachen.
Aber die Kombination aus allem ist
einfach super nice in Postgres und das
meiste ist in Postgres auch
verhältnismäßig einfach zu verwenden.
Deswegen, wenn es nach
mir geht, Postgres
der Default
für alles. Und es
kostet noch nicht mal was.
Es gibt für mich keinen Grund
was anderes als Postgres zu verwenden, außer
ganz spezielle Gründe,
die für
diese eine Anwendung so relevant sind, dass
sie überwiegen, liegen vor.
Aber ansonsten sollte Postgres aus
meiner Sicht Default für alles sein.
So, hat funktioniert, Leute.
Mein Package-Manager geht wieder.
Schauen wir mal kurz, ob es
Upgrades für
Jetbrain-Geschichten gibt.
Wegen welchen Gründen ist die Toolbox gerade
gecrashed.
Arch, by the way.
Neo Fetch Flex.
Ist das jetzt komplett ab?
Ach nee, das hat sich geupgradet und hat sich neu gestartet.
Verstehe.
Exzellent. Rider gibt es
eine neue Version.
23.4. Witzmann, lehn dich langsam.
Zeit für 24.1.
Wann kommt denn Rider
24.1?
Ich meine, es ist
fast April.
Übrigens, 1. April bin ich
ein Jahr jetzt im neuen Job.
Kommt mir selbst gar nicht
so lange vor. Ging super schnell.
Ging super schnell.
Was ist Rider? Eine C-Sharp
IDE und
eine C-Sharp IDE nicht von Microsoft.
Aber sie ist besser als Visual Studio.
Und sie funktioniert Cross-Plattform auf
Windows, Linux und Mac.
Also wenn man C-Sharp
entwickelt, ist Rider das Beste, was man machen kann.
Man kann sich 30 Tage
Demo-Version
registrieren dafür.
Man kann sich auch
mehrere Accounts machen, um
die Demo-Version zu extenden.
Aber ich
finde, es ist den Preis wert. Also ich habe das
JetBrains All Desktop Package jetzt
glaube ich schon im dritten oder vierten Jahr
oder so. Also ich kriege jetzt schon
den günstigsten Preis davon.
Oh nein, der Teufel, Leute.
Und es lohnt sich.
Hast du eigentlich
Einarbeitung benötigt? Klar.
Du benötigst immer
Einarbeitung, wenn du in einem neuen Job bist.
Das liegt daran, du kannst alle Tools
perfekt kennen, die dein neuer Arbeitgeber
einsetzt, aber du weißt ja nicht, wie
die die einsetzen. Und das ist ja
oftmals der Knackpunkt.
Oder welche
Eigenheiten, welche
konfigurierten Dinger die haben.
Ja, zum Beispiel
der Arbeitgeber,
wo ich jetzt bin, die stehen total
auf Se-Linux.
Oder Se-Linux? Ich sage immer
Se-Linux, weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig ausspricht.
Und das
fuckt mich so ab, Se-Linux,
Leute. Das ist einfach immer
Try and Error, bis es funktioniert.
Aber ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe
mich damit bisher auch nie großartig
auseinandergesetzt, weil, wenn ich es mal brauchte,
Try and Error, bis es funktioniert,
mittlerweile blicke ich da ein bisschen besser durch.
Auch wenn es mich immer noch
abfuckt. Se-Linux ist wirklich
ein kompletter Pains-Champ.
Wer das nicht kennt, ich versuche mal
ganz kurz zu erklären, was Se-Linux ist.
Was? Se-Linux ist
CBT. Was ist
CBT? Warum
gibt es für alles irgendwelche Abkürzungen?
Was ist CBT?
Mensch, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich...
Ist CBT...
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ach, dafür steht das. Okay.
Verstehe. Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, so fühlt sich Frischi...
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das würde ich ähnlich sehen.
Also,
Se-Linux ist
ein Policy Framework, wo du
die Rechte von
Prozessen noch ein bisschen weiter
einschränken kannst. Beziehungsweise,
eigentlich machst du es umgedreht. Du erlaubst
für Prozesse nur explizit
das, was erlaubt ist. Und das geht über die
Standardberechtigung unter Linux raus.
Standardberechtigung unter Linux sind ja im Prinzip
zwei Sachen. Filesystemrechte
und, ja,
unter welchem User läuft
der Prozess. So, das war's.
Mehr oder weniger. Du hast ein paar
Basic Sachen, die
nicht gehen. Ja, du darfst keinen Port aufmachen
unter 1024, wenn
du nicht root bist und solche Sachen. Aber ansonsten
ist es unter Linux jetzt nicht so,
dass du standardmäßig
superfein festlegen
kannst und möchtest,
was ein Prozess darf und was
nicht. So, mit Se-Linux kannst du
das. Mit Se-Linux kannst du zum Beispiel
noch so eine, nennen wir es mal
so eine Schicht beim
Aufruf von Funktionen dazwischen schalten,
die dann nachguckt, darf
der Prozess das auch wirklich, ja?
Also, darf der Prozess
jetzt nicht nur auf die Datei
zugreifen, sondern darf
der Prozess,
ja, keine Ahnung,
was ist immer was naheliegendes,
fällt mir jetzt gerade pauschal
gar nichts ein. Darf der Prozess
die Uhrzeit auslesen, zum Beispiel?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung,
ob man das mit Se-Linux beschränken kann, aber
wahrscheinlich.
Also, sowas kannst du damit
blocken, ja, was du auf normaler Berechtigungsebene
nicht blocken kannst.
Und das läuft dann
standardmäßig so, dass du alles blockst
und explizit für bestimmte Prozesse
was freigibst.
Das ist
aber wirklich komplett
abfuck, ja?
Aber ne gescheite Regel haben sie da auch nicht drinnen,
weil die Regeln sind auch komplett, ja,
ja.
Genau, Context, Network, Ports
und es ist super
weird, Se-Linux, ja.
Genauso verwirrend, wie es hier aussieht, ist es
auch. Und dann hast du halt Prozesse,
die nicht funktionieren, weil sie nach
einem Update vielleicht auf was zugreifen
wollen, was Se-Linux vorher nicht erlaubt
hatten, da musst du das mitschneiden,
gucken, was es ist, und das dann freigeben
ist voll für den Arsch, ja?
Das mache ich auch oft, also
ich habe auf keinen meiner Kisten
selbst auf Servern in der Cloud und so
Se-Linux an. Also
es ist nicht, dass es nicht sinnvoll ist, das sage ich nicht,
ja? Das kann Security-technisch
schon sinnvoll sein.
Hey Max, würdest du einen beruflichen
Umstieg in die IT-Branche eher per Umschulung
queren oder durch Ausbildung? Ausbildung
ist sicherlich das, wie soll ich sagen,
basierteste,
was du machen kannst.
Da gibt es dann auch keine
größeren Diskussionen, da
ist dann halt jemand, der eine Ausbildung in dem Bereich hat.
Du kannst es aber, wenn du Ahnung
von dem hast, was du machst und dich damit
beschäftigt hast, wenn du vielleicht jetzt nicht aus der
komplett, also komplett
fachfremden Branche kommst, ist der
Quereinstieg so einfach wie nie.
Und mit Umschulen kenne ich mich nicht aus,
keine Ahnung. Ich weiß, dass es
Umschulungen vom Arbeitsamt gibt,
das ist dann quasi, da
darfst du am Ende auch die Physi-Abschlussprüfung
machen, da brauchst du dann
einmal ein dreiviertel Jahre Praktikum in irgendeinem
Betrieb und sowas. Kann auch
funktionieren, keine Ahnung.
Davon habe ich persönlich keinen Plan.
Mich auch nicht großartig damit beschäftigt.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass der Quereinstieg
zur Zeit so einfach ist, wie nie
zuvor, weil die alle händeringend Leute suchen, aber da
musst du halt schon ein bisschen was kennen.
Quereinsteiger will ja keiner
quasi als Azubi behandeln.
Als Quereinsteiger bist du ja jemand,
der schon Ahnung hat
und was machen kann.
Schwer zu sagen. Also wenn du
jetzt noch nicht, sagen wir mal, irgendwie 35
plus oder sowas bist,
dann ist eine Ausbildung, eine zweite Ausbildung
auch kein Problem. Also ich habe meine Ausbildung auch erst
mit 24 oder so
gemacht, die
Physi-Ausbildung. Oder?
Habe ich das?
Ja, so in dem Dreh.
Gut.
Was benutzt ihr? Eine IBM
Informix DB habe ich noch nie gehört.
Glücklicherweise kenne ich auch nicht
den ganzen Business Enterprise Shit.
Bin ich auch ganz froh drum.
Kann man machen, überhaupt kein Ding.
Ja. Also aktuell
ist die beste Zeit, das zu machen.
Gerade wenn man einen aktuellen Beruf hat,
den man keinen Bock mehr hat.
Oder wo die Zukunftsaussichten
mies aussehen.
Die suchen händeringend Leute aktuell.
Und auch wenn das vielleicht
manchen Leuten im Arbeitsamt vorschwebt,
dass du jeden
Dude, der keinerlei
Technikbezug hat, hat irgendwie
umschulen könntest auf Fachinformatiker,
ist das halt Blödsinn.
Das heißt, es wird auf absehbare
Zeit, wenn nicht für immer,
aber für immer ist so lang, also auf sehr lange Zeit,
wird es nicht genug Leute geben.
Und auch wenn
AI kommt und das eintritt,
wovor sie irgendwie alle Panik
haben, AI macht uns überflüssig,
sag ich ganz ehrlich, AI wird erstmal
sehr viele andere Sachen überflüssig machen,
bevor das wirklich
und ich sag jetzt mal absichtlich
Fachkräfte,
also IT-Fachkräfte
überflüssig macht.
Jemand, der Druckerpatronen wechselt, ist für
mich auch eine
Fachkraft in gewisser
Weise, weil das wird
AI nie schaffen, Druckerpatronen wechseln.
Aber natürlich ist
der Druckerpatronen-Wechsler jetzt nicht unbedingt
das, was man sich da,
wenn man in der IT arbeitet, vorstellt.
Und das ist oftmals auch nicht das Hauptsächliche,
was die Leute machen. Also bevor
AI uns da ersetzt, wird es erstmal
jede Menge
anderen Jobs ersetzen.
Irgendwelche
Bullshit-BWL-Shops zum Beispiel.
Webentwicklung kann sein.
Webentwicklung ist glaube ich
auch das
im Anwendungs-Entwicklungsbereich, wo
ich sag mal so, das
beliebteste Quereinsteiger-Thema ist,
rate ich jetzt mal, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so ist,
weil ich glaube, Webentwicklung ist das,
was viele Leute als Einstieg machen,
was ich ja auch als Einstieg empfehle,
immer wenn mich einer fragt, Max, was ist die beste
Einstiegsprogrammiersprache, sag ich ja auch immer,
fang mit JavaScript an, ist die Einstiegshürde einfach
am geringsten.
Und, weil jeder damit irgendwie
schon mal ein bisschen in Berührung gekommen ist,
denke ich mal. Das Ding ist aber auch da,
wirklich gescheite Leute
zu finden, die Erfahrung haben,
die Ahnung haben, die wissen, was sie
machen, die mehr als
so 0815 Zeug können,
ist auch da schwierig.
Achso, ich habe gesagt, wir wollen uns noch eine Stellenanzeige
angucken, bevor wir jetzt hier zu YouTube
Videos und so übergehen.
Brain Factory, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, gell?
Öh, Azure AD, MonkaS, Alter.
Okay, so, wo sind wir?
Was ist da mal stehen geblieben? Das da?
Junior System Administrator, Cloud Virtualisierung,
Senior System Administrator
für Verzeichnisdienste,
EGIT Verzeichnisdienste, das klingt so,
das klingt, die Stadt Essen, die haben wir doch
schon gehabt, die haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Das war
abartig schlecht, die Stellenanzeige,
die war so schlecht, dass ich jetzt eine Woche später
immer noch weiß, dass die super schlecht war.
Plata Entwickler,
Cyber Security,
DevOps Engineer, Linux,
okay. Also, da gucken wir uns jetzt
das hier an.
So.
Ich sehe hier keinen Job.
Glücklicherweise gibt's den
Obstkorb.
Kekaloo.
Was sind denn die Benefits hier?
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was sie suchen, aber
Benefits sind
Leihzeit und flexibles Arbeiten
im Homeoffice. Okay, das ist gut.
Zuschuss des Dienstfahrers,
Dienstroller oder Dienstscooter.
Ja, machen
viele mittlerweile. Ich hab trotzdem mal ein neues
Fahrrad einfach so ge... gebyt.
Hochwertige Arbeitsausstattung.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Benefit.
Laptop höhenverstellbar. Das finde ich
gut, dass die das schreiben. Ja.
Das ist echt was, wo ich finde,
dass da zu wenig Wert draufgelegt
wird.
Höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch,
gescheiter Stuhl, gescheiter Ausstattung.
Bringt ja nix, wenn die Leute acht
Stunden da hocken hast, denen tut der Rücken weh.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge. Ja, gut.
Obst, kostenloses Kaffee und Wasser.
Firmen Events. Okay.
Das ist für mich kein Benefit.
Ich hasse Firmen Events.
Deswegen gehe ich auch auf keine
Firmen Events, die nicht Pflicht
sind und wenn sie Pflicht sind, sind sie selbstverständlich
Arbeitszeit. Weihnachtsfeier ist
bei uns keine Pflicht.
Sommerfest ist keine Pflicht und die anderen
Sachen sind auch keine Pflicht.
Ich glaube das einzige Pflicht
Event, was wir haben,
einmal im Jahr, ist so ein Teambuilding Workshop.
Und der letzte Teambuilding Workshop, der hat mich jetzt nicht
vielleicht, hat mich vielleicht jetzt nicht
unbedingt in Verzückung versetzt,
dass ich gesagt habe, boah geil,
das muss ich jeden Monat machen.
Aber ich habe schon
Nervigere gesehen.
Und das, das ging,
das ging ganz gut klar, ja.
Ja genau, wenn es Pflicht ist, muss es
Arbeitszeit sein.
Und by the way, nochmal erwähnt
an der Stelle, wenn es Pflichtveranstaltungen
gibt, die irgendwo in Deutschland sind
und ihr müsst rumkurven, dann ist
die Fahrzeit Arbeitszeit.
Ihr müsst nur zu eurem Arbeitsplatz
quasi
von der Zeit her in Kauf nehmen.
Also wenn jetzt einer von euch sagt, also mal
angenommen, ich fahre von Hanau nach Frankfurt
auf die Arbeit, so,
und da ist mein Arbeitsplatz.
Das ist keine Arbeitszeit. Wenn die jetzt aber sagen,
Max, morgen musst
du unbedingt in irgendeiner
Filiale in
weiß ich nicht, Hamburg
was machen, was nicht wirklich passiert,
aber, müsst du was machen,
dann ist das Arbeitszeit
von Frankfurt nach Hamburg zu fahren.
Muss man vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal erwähnen.
Zählt das auch für Fortbildungen?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Also wenn die Pflicht sind, auf jeden Fall.
Ansonsten
kenne ich mich damit nicht aus.
Nicht genug aus, um das beantworten zu können.
Hast du
gesehen, Rust wurde vom Whitehouse
als sicherste Programmiersprache anerkannt.
Hä, das macht doch überhaupt
keinen Sinn. Das sind
zwei komplett unterschiedliche
paar Anwendungszwecke,
Schuhe. Sicher, dass sie C-Sharp
und nicht C meinen?
Oder C++ oder sowas?
Weil, C-Sharp ist nicht
irgendwie unsicherer als Rust oder so.
C-Sharp ist managed.
Es ist, schau mal, memory safe
by default.
Wobei, das mit managed bin ich
C-Sharp checkt halt Array-Zugriffe und
du machst ja normalerweise dort nix mit
Raw-Pointer und Index ins Array,
wenn es safe ist.
Das ist sicher
by default. Vieles von dem, was Rust
dir abfängt, hast du in C-Sharp
gar nicht. Der Vorteil
von Rust ist, ich glaube die meinen
C++. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ah ja, dann ist gut.
Ergibt ja auch Sinn.
Also,
der Anwendungsfall von Rust
ist aus meiner Sicht,
lass mal hier.
To migrate to memory safe languages, but
only mentions Rust.
An earlier
lists C-Sharp, Go, Java,
Ruby, Swift.
Rust kann dir auch nicht
absolut garantieren, dass dein Code
safe ist. Du kannst
in Rust auch unsafe
machen und du kannst
in Rust auch cheaten mit
Lifetimes, indem du sie static
markierst.
Also, du kannst
auch in Rust cheaten.
Also, auch Rust garantiert es dir
nicht hundertprozentig.
Wenn du Rust aber, sagen wir mal, ordentlich
verwendest, dann schon. Also,
ich finde, das ist eigentlich
ein ziemlich blöder Vergleich,
weil
Rust ist keine managed Sprache
in dem Sinn, wie es beispielsweise C-Sharp ist,
aber trotzdem weitgehend
memory safe.
Also, der Vorteil von Rust,
sagen wir mal, im Vergleich zu sowas wie C ist,
oder im Vergleich
zu sowas wie C++,
weil C++ besonders wirr ist,
ist,
Rust ist
unmanaged, aber, also der Vorteil
von Rust ist,
oder ich muss es anders sagen, der
Einsatzzweck, und ich finde aus meiner Sicht
auch der einzig sinnvolle Einsatzzweck
für Rust ist,
wenn du eine Software entwickeln möchtest,
die, sagen wir mal,
Anforderungen hat,
so performant
wie irgendwie möglich zu sein,
und gleichermaßen so
memory safe,
nenn es mal so in Anführungszeichen so sicher,
wie möglich zu sein.
Das ist nicht so wichtig,
wie es sich anhört für viele
Softwareprojekte.
Also, beispielsweise hier die 0815
Windows Desktop Anwendung,
da ist die Performance, sagen wir mal, zweitrangig.
Das ist schnell genug, auch in anderen
Programmiersprachen,
auch in komplett managed Programmiersprachen,
mit Garbage Collector und allem drumherum.
Bei Spielen ist es umgedreht,
bei Spielen ist die Performance enorm wichtig,
aber der Security Aspekt
nicht so wild.
Meistens zumindest, ja.
Weil, was kann hier im schlimmsten Fall passieren?
Ja, das Spiel verhält sich
falsch, irgendwie, oder es crasht.
Das ist das Schlimmste, was hier bei einem, sagen wir mal,
Singleplayer-Game passieren kann.
Selbst dafür ist Rust
vielleicht nicht sinnvoll.
Wofür Rust sinnvoll ist, ist zum Beispiel
eine CSS-Engine für den Browser.
Ein
JavaScript-Interpreter für den Browser,
zum Beispiel, ja. Also dort, wo
super krass Performance
gebraucht wird und
das Ganze zur
Compile-Time unmanaged
immer noch so sicher
wie möglich sein muss. Dafür ist
Rust gut.
Für einen Großteil der Software ist
Rust nicht
sinnvoll, weil
du erkaufst dir Rust durch
verringerte
Entwickler-Produktivität. Und das ist so.
Und das kann mir kein Rust-Fail
der Welt ausreden,
dass das nicht so ist.
Du bist in Rust
immer langsamer im Entwickeln
und genervter von Rust
beim Entwickeln, wie beispielsweise
in C-Sharp oder
Python oder Ruby oder
Java
mal außen vor.
Irgendwas anderes, was nicht Java ist.
Ja.
Bis zu einem gewissen Teil sicherlich,
bis zu einem
gewissen Teil sicherlich,
aber wenn du beides ähnlich kannst,
wirst du in anderen...
Also mal angenommen, du hast jemand, der richtig gut Rust kann
und jemand, der richtig gut, sagen wir mal,
C-Sharp kann.
Dann... Und du sagst
denen, ey, bau mal
ein simples Web-Backend,
wo du
5 API-Aufrufe
machen kannst. Leute,
in Rust
musst du dann rumhantieren
mit irgendwelchen HTTP Server
Library, mit Tokio, mit
sonst was.
Das kannst du alles lernen.
Das kannst du alles lernen, ja.
Aber ich kann euch sagen,
der...
Also meine Vermutung zumindest, man müsste das mal ausbringen,
meine Vermutung ist,
der C-Sharp Entwickler ist ungefähr
mal doppelt so schnell fertig,
wie der Rust Entwickler.
Dafür ist unterm Strich
die Rust Anwendung
sicherlich eine ganze Ecke
performanter,
als die C-Sharp Anwendung. Gerade unter
heavy Load, wenn du viele Objekte
allocaten musst und
Garbage Collector Runs
zuschlagen. Also unter richtig
fettem Load
wird sich die Rust Anwendung deutlich
performanter und wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so speicherhungrig verhalten,
wie die C-Sharp Anwendung.
Aber wenn man es rein von der Entwicklerzeit
sieht, ist die C-Sharp Anwendung
wahrscheinlich doppelt so schnell fertig.
Also dafür ist Rust gut. Rust ist gut
für alles, was super krasse
Performance braucht und
nichtgehend safe sein muss.
Dann macht Rust Sinn. Also zum Beispiel
wenn man jetzt was, wenn man
eine Software hat, die in C programmiert ist
und
sagt, hey
mir ist die Performance wichtig
deswegen habe ich es halt in C gemacht
und ich möchte jetzt allerdings ausschließen,
dass ich ein paar
Speicherprobleme habe, die ich eventuell
haben könnte und meine Anwendung ist so
relevant und muss so
stable laufen oder
im Umgangsfall so
memory safe sein, dass es keine
Sicherheitsprobleme geben kann, dann ist Rust
eine gute Idee. Ansonsten macht es aus
meiner Sicht keinen Sinn, Software in Rust
zu entwickeln.
The Filance ist doch mit Rust programmiert, keine Ahnung, kann sein.
Also ich
bin nicht der große Rust Entwickler.
Wie gesagt, ich mache
nicht so viel in Rust. Wir haben im Stream ein bisschen was
in Rust schon gemacht, da hat man auch gesehen,
dass ich jetzt nicht da
extrem viel Ahnung von habe.
Aber
ein paar Sachen, also Rust hat schon coole
wie soll man sagen,
coole Konzepte.
Also was ich in Rust mag ist zum Beispiel,
dass alles
gecheckt werden muss
und konsistent gecheckt werden muss.
Es ist nicht so wie in Go,
wo du mal Panics hast, mal
Recovers hast und mal irgendwie
Errorobjekte hast und sowas.
In Rust musst du
eigentlich alles explizit
checken, ansonsten crasht
dir die Rust.
Kann man das noch Runtime nennen bei Rust?
Wenn du was
unwrappst in Rust
und es ist nichts drin, crash.
Also Rust möchte
explizit checken
von Returnwerten. Du musst in
Rust Returnwerte explizit checken.
Weil ansonsten kannst du nicht drauf
zugreifen. Du kannst in Rust nicht sagen,
ey, ne Funktion returnt was
und
ich greif da jetzt einfach mal
drauf zu
und ja, du,
entweder ist es da oder nicht. Nein, in Rust
du musst explizit checken,
ist es ein
Error, der returnt wurde?
Ist es ein Value?
Und dann musst du eine Funktion aufrufen,
unwrap den Value da draus.
Also du musst Returnwerts checken in Rust.
Da kommst du nicht drum rum.
Und dementsprechend returnen Funktionen
in Rust auch sehr selten
direkt Werte, sondern
returnen in der Regel
Result Types.
...
Wo dann halt drin steht, ja
da ist ein Wert drin
und nein, kein Wert drin,
dafür ein Fehler und sowas in der Richtung.
Das finde ich cool und
das ist was, was ich in C-Sharp
auch vermehrt benutze.
Anstelle von Exceptions,
dort wo es sich anbietet.
Also quasi, anstatt
mal angenommen du hast eine Funktion,
die macht einen Web Request,
du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel
du hast eine Funktion, die macht einen Web Request
von irgendeiner API und da
kriegt es dann irgendeine Response
und da könntest du jetzt sagen, okay
wenn
die Response
von der API ist
was auch immer
Value not found,
dann wirfst du eine Exception,
Value not found exception.
So, das war der traditionelle Ansatz,
das in C-Sharp zu machen.
Ich habe es, ich handel es mittlerweile
eher so, wie gesagt,
ich bin kein irgendwie professioneller Softwareentwickler,
der damit sein Geld verdient,
aber ich handel es in der Regel mittlerweile so
und das ist das, was mir Sprachen
unter anderem wie Rust,
aber auch der immer
funktionalere Einschlag von C-Sharp gezeigt hat.
Ich handel es mittlerweile, behandle das mittlerweile so.
Stellt euch vor,
ich habe eine Funktion, die einen Web Request
macht, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Sekunde.
Ich war jetzt ein bisschen sidetracked,
aber wurscht.
Der Punch Champ am Start. Haben wir irgendwas mit
einem Web Backend hier vielleicht?
Ist egal, ich mache einfach mal irgendwas
auf.
Oh, meine
Schriftart ist broken. Warum das denn?
Warum ist meine Schriftart hier kaputt?
Wurscht. Wir machen mal nur mal ein Beispiel.
Also,
stellt euch mal vor, hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
getValue, bester Funktionsnamen.
So, int.
So muss das Ding heißen, getValue.
So, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Das ist eine Funktion aus...
getValue, beste.
Weißt sofort, was Sache ist.
Return 1, so.
Mal angenommen, das Ding hier
müsste zum getValue machen, müsste
das ein Web Request machen.
Also, var httpclient
gleich new httpclient
und jetzt sagst du hier,
wollen wir das Ganze async?
Komm, scheiß drauf.
httpclient get...
Hat das nicht auch eine SyncGet-Methode mittlerweile?
Ich bilde mir ein, das hat es.
Ja doch, hat es.
Machen wir es doch, async.
Dann sieht es aber...
Egal, get...
Oh, string...
Blob.com
slash lul.
Ist ja auch wurscht, wir machen das immer nur exemplarisch.
So, da würde ich ein Web Request
machen, so result
und dieses result
ist, da steht der Wert drin, den
ich haben will, ja, also quasi hier
result value, so.
Das geht jetzt nicht, weil da nicht wirklich was drin steht.
Aber angenommen, sowas will ich machen.
Jetzt ist die klassische Sache, was passieren kann,
ist, diese API,
das kann ja dieser Web-Aufruf,
der kann ja verschiedenste Arten schief gehen.
Die Domain kann
falsch sein, oder aber
die API hier antwortet, value not found.
Also sagen wir mal, es gibt
einen Fehler, also
hier könnte zum Beispiel
eine Response kommen, wo drin
steht, hier, value not found
oder so, oder hier
lul.w not found kommt dann.
Vielleicht falscher Aufruf. So, das ist eine Response.
Klassische Sache
war, du hast, du hast
da einen
try-catch-Block drum herum gemacht.
Du hast gesagt,
hier, wenn da irgendwie ein Fehler
bei den Requests auftritt, dann
werf eine Exception
und entweder kann man die Exception handeln,
ja, mit einem default value oder nicht.
Aber,
was ich nach Möglichkeiten mittlerweile
mache, ist folgendes.
Ich werf eine Exception für
Netzwerkfehler,
aber für
gültige,
also für
auf http-Ebene
gültige Responses
gebe ich ein Result zurück.
Also, man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, man macht hier
einen try-except drum herum
und catcht hier
sagen wir mal, irgendwie die
http, gibt es hier eine http-Exception
oder wie auch immer, ich weiß nicht,
wie das, wie das richtig heißt.
Irgendwie, man catcht hier,
hier fängt man die Sachen
für, ähm,
keine Ahnung, äh,
äh, 404
oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, äh,
unreachable
und, und sonstige Geschichten.
So, und
halt Übertragungsfehler
und da würdest du dann sagen, hier,
throw new exception
bla, blub, vielleicht hast du einen eigenen Exception-Typ,
wo dann, wo dann irgendwas drin ist.
Ja, ansonsten
würdest, müsstest du das gar nicht machen.
Wir machen kein Error-Handling,
weil da bei uns alles immer stand,
ja, keine Ahnung hier.
So, also du hast hier irgendeine throw, hier,
hier, custom exception,
würdest, könntest du, könntest du werfen, so.
Jetzt ist das Ding,
wenn das Ding hier antwortet,
lol, we not found,
dann kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten, ist das eine Exception-Wert
oder nicht?
Es ist ja eigentlich keine Übertragung,
die, die schief gegangen ist,
sondern es ist eine gültige Antwort
und die, die Response
ist halt lol, we not found.
Das ist auf Anwendungsebene.
Das heißt, anstatt jetzt hier
irgendwie dann noch eine Exception
zu werfen an der Stelle, wenn da lol, we not found
drin ist, kannst du
sagen, du returnst jetzt sowas wie result,
wir machen das immer nur als Beispiel,
ja, das gibt es so standardmäßig in .NET nicht,
ähm, du returnst
jetzt ein result,
und der result kann beispielsweise
einen error und einen int enthalten.
Und dann sagst
du, okay, wenn hier lol,
we not found steht,
dann würdest du hier sagen, äh, hier result
gleich new result, was es jetzt nicht gibt,
ja, und dann würdest du
in result eben
den, den error irgendwie setzen
auf lol, we not found, so.
Versteht man, was ich meine? Also du unterscheidest
zwischen Übertragungsproblem,
das sind wirklich echte
Exceptions, oder
auf Anwendungslogik
Ebene, Übertragung hat
geklappt, aber du bist nicht damit zufrieden,
was das Ding returnt.
Und das ist was, das habe ich früher
nicht unterschieden, ich habe früher immer
Exceptions geschmissen, so nach dem Motto,
ja gut, hat natürlich funktioniert, wirfst eine Exception,
und der Aufrufer muss sich drum kümmern,
aber eigentlich ist es viel sinniger, zu sagen,
hey, es ist nur eine Exception,
wenn die Übertragung nicht funktioniert.
Weil das ist ja
echt was Außergewöhnliches, wie so,
wie sollst du es handhaben,
wenn die Übertragung zum Server nicht funktioniert
hat? Wie sollst du es übertragen,
wenn der Server nicht erreichbar ist? Wie sollst du es übertragen,
wenn dein Netzwerk kaputt ist, wenn deine Internetverbindung
gerade nicht funktioniert?
Wie sollst du das handeln? Das kannst
du nicht handeln, da musst du eine Exception werfen,
und der Aufrufer kann entscheiden, was er machen soll.
Wenn allerdings die
Übertragung funktioniert, und die API
Response irgendwas drinstehen hat,
was dir bloß nicht gefällt,
dann kannst du
das returnen,
und der Aufrufer
kann sich die Fehlermeldung angucken,
also das Errorobjekt angucken,
und sich dann überlegen, was will ich denn jetzt machen?
Dann muss der kein Try-Catch mehr drum herum machen.
Ne, wenn
HTTP Error ist, dann ist es
schon eine Exception.
Das ist auch sowas, da kann man sich drüber
streiten. Ich finde es beispielsweise
auch nicht sinnvoll,
API Errors über
HTTP Response Codes
zu handeln.
Also,
mal angenommen, du machst jetzt einen API Aufruf
blub.com
slash lul. Der Aufruf
an sich ist vollkommen okay,
aber lul,
die ID lul, konnte beispielsweise
in der Datenbank nicht gefunden werden.
Dann ist das für mich ein 200,
aber in der
Response sollte drinstehen, ID not found,
oder, ja, was weiß ich,
API Error, oder sowas.
Ich finde, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinger.
HTTP Status Codes
sind für, ja,
Protokollübertragungsfehler,
nicht für Anwendungslogikfehler.
ID not found
in der Datenbank ist ein
Anwendungsfehler. Das würde ich
nicht in den Response Code reinschreiben.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten,
aber ich finde das der
sinnvolle Ansatz. Ich weiß, das machen viele nicht,
aber warum, warum ist
ein Anwendungslogikfehler auf einmal
ein HTTP Response Code? Weil,
ein HTTP Response Code hat
eine genau definierte
ähm,
Bedeutung. Also es gibt
Beschreibungen dafür, welche
HTTP Response Code
was bedeutet.
Ah.
Also ich find's
nicht so sinnig. Und genau,
und 404 not found
ist keine,
ist kein API Fehler.
404 not found ist,
da gibt es nix. Und da wird das auch
nix geben.
Die Domain ist, äh, oder die Seite
ist falsch, der, der Aufruf ist falsch,
ich hab mal, keine Ahnung, man hat, man hat vielleicht
äh,
API anstatt slash API geschrieben und
sowas. Alles gut. 404 gibt es nicht.
Ist falsch. Ist rein logisch falsch.
Wenn es, ähm,
wenn es einen,
wenn der Aufruf richtig ist,
ja, aber das sind,
das sind unterschiedliche, das sind
unterschiedliche Fehler.
Das sind unterschiedliche
Fehler.
Eine auf Anwendungslogik
Ebene
User not found
ist kein 404.
Nee, war das nicht so, dass 500
temporäre Fehler sind und 400 permanente
Fehler?
War's nicht so rum?
500 sind temporäre, 400
sind permanente? Ja, ist doch gut.
Ah, nee, dann hab ich, hä?
Dann bring ich's durcheinander.
Ist aber auch egal, für das, was ich, äh, gesagt hab.
Macht's keinen Unterschied.
Ja, das, das find ich, das find ich sinnvoll.
Ja, das find ich sinnvoll.
Ja, falscher Pfad, da kann
es nie was drunter geben.
Das ist ein 404, das ist okay.
Falscher Parameter, wenn auf
Anwendungslogik Ebene da nichts passieren kann,
dann find ich's durchaus okay zu sagen
und nen ordentlichen Error
in der Response mitzuschicken.
Nee, also ich find, ich find's genauso
richtig. Also,
oder nicht richtig. Also, je nachdem, wie,
wie's jetzt gemeint. Also, ich finde, es ist
sinnvoll, wenn im JSON steht
User ID not found als
Response, aber der
Response, der,
der HTTP Response Code ist 200.
Du hast ja ein
Valid HTTP Request mit einer
Valid Response, also du kriegst,
du machst ein Request und kriegst
eine gültige Antwort.
Die Antwort gefällt dir dann zwar
am Ende nicht, weil in der Antwort
User ID not found steht,
aber User ID not found ist
Anwendungslogik. User ID not found ist
nicht, ähm, Webserver
Fehler oder irgendwas in
der Richtung. Man kann sich sicherlich
dann darüber streiten, welchen 200er
man schickt, ja. Gibt's ja auch
verschiedene, verschiedene Möglichkeiten, da
weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht.
Aber genau das ist, das ist der Punkt.
Wenn ich, wenn ich zu dem Server hingehe
und sage, gib mir mal Infos
zum User Max. Und der,
und der Server guckt nach und stellt fest,
aha, User Max gibt es
nicht, aber es gibt einen User
Maxi. Und,
ähm, der Server antwortet
mir dann, User Max not found,
did you mean Maxi?
Das ist kein 404!
Das ist eindeutig
ein, jawoll, Response hat geklappt,
alles gut,
und jetzt mach was
mit der Response
auf Anwendungsebene. Hat nichts mehr mit
HTTP zu tun. Ja.
Also, so sehe ich das.
Wie du das handhabst, ja mit
dem, was in der Response drinne steht.
Du musst ja wissen, was dein Server
antwortet, damit du es richtig verarbeiten
kannst. Das könntest du ja anhand von
HTTP-Codes auch nicht wirklich,
wenn du nicht weißt, wann es wie antwortet.
Da ist es sogar so rum besser, weil dann
HTTP-Codes nicht für irgendwas missbraucht werden.
Ja, dazu gibt es
dann beispielsweise irgendeine Swagger
API Endpunkt oder sowas, wo dann halt drinne
steht, wie können Response Objekte
aussehen, und dann weißt du, okay, wenn ich
diese API aufrufe, dann kann es als
mögliche Antwort das und das geben.
Und dann muss ich das handhaben.
Dann bekomme ich dann ein JSON als Antwort zurück.
Das JSON deserialisiere
ich in irgendein Objekt oder
in irgendein Errorobjekt oder in was auch immer.
Und dann gucke ich nach,
was will
ich denn machen im Fall von UserID not found.
Ja, ich weiß, es ist
ein heiß diskutiertes
Ding und wahrscheinlich gibt es da auch
kein
abschließendes Richtig und Falsch.
Guck mal, machen wir das Beispiel
mal anders.
Sagen wir mal, es wäre kein
Get-Request, sondern
es wäre ein Post.
Yantari ist genau das gleiche, habe ich mir auch gerade
gedacht. Stell dir mal vor, es wäre ein
Post-Request, okay?
So, du machst ein Post-Request,
du machst ein
Post,
du machst ein Post auf
bloop.com
api slash
user, okay?
Und dort
hast du dann irgendwie einen JSON
drinne, User,
Max, okay?
Das schickst du da hin.
Wenn jetzt der User Max nicht
gefunden wird, oder sagen wir mal,
sagen wir mal, die Response von der API wäre
jetzt,
wäre jetzt ein Objekt, sagen wir mal
hier, keine Ahnung,
Status, Error
und dann Error
Message gleich,
keine Ahnung, User Max
not found
Did you mean Maxi?
So.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre die Response davon.
Ist das wirklich ein
404?
Aus meiner Sicht ist es kein 404.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es,
der Post-Request hat wunderbar funktioniert,
aber die
Anwendung möchte dir
mitteilen, das hier.
Und das hat nichts mehr mit HTTP zu tun.
Der HTTP-Request hat
komplett fehlerfrei ohne jegliche Probleme
funktioniert. Das ist kein
404. Das ist
irgendein 200, weil die Übertragung
okay war. Sonst, guck mal,
jetzt mal seriously, sonst hast du ja
noch ganz andere Probleme.
Stell dir mal vor,
das hier wäre jetzt ein,
ich weiß, wir sind etwas sidetracked, aber trotzdem.
Stell dir mal vor, das hier wäre
jetzt ein 404.
Wie unterscheidest du dann
ein 404, der
eine Error Response enthält,
oder ein 404, der
wirklich not found ist?
Wie machst du das? Gar nicht.
Willst du dann jeden 404 kontrollieren,
ob das denn dich doch was mitgeschickt hat?
Also stell dir mal vor, das wäre
ein 404. So,
guck mal, du machst einen Post,
du machst einen Post hier rauf, okay?
Du machst einen Post auf,
da, du hast dich verschrieben.
Das gibt einen 404, okay.
Warum gibt es einen 404? Nur weil das ganze
Ding nicht existiert und nie existieren wird.
Aber du machst hier einen Post
und der User existiert nicht.
Deswegen ist das kein 404.
Und deswegen würde ich auch keine
HTTP-Status-Codes missbrauchen, um
sowas hier zu signalisieren.
Weil sonst hast du jetzt das Ding,
jetzt müsstest du den 404 checken,
Moment, hat denn der
404 vielleicht noch irgendwie eine
Response mit drin, die ich parsen
muss und sowas? Also ich glaube,
man versteht, was ich meine. Und gerade an dem Beispiel
sieht man auch, dass es eigentlich
keinen Sinn macht, hier einen 404 zu werfen.
Hier macht es Sinn, einen 404 zu werfen.
Hier hast du aber auch keine Response,
die irgendwie anwendungsrelevant wäre,
weil der Request nicht funktioniert.
Sobald der Request funktioniert,
so wie hier, dann ist das kein 404,
sondern irgendein 200er.
Und dann musst du auf
Anwendungsebene gucken, musst du das JSON parsen,
musst du gucken, okay, Status, Error,
okay, Error-Message, was mache ich jetzt damit?
Warum bist du nicht auf der Gamescom?
Du sagst doch, du magst
viele...
Ja, ich bin da richtiger Fan
von vielen Menschen auf engem Raum, ja.
Ne, Gamescom ist einfach langweilig.
Ach, Gamescom LAN!
Wo es gar nicht da sowas gibt.
Ich gehe auch nicht mehr auf die normale Gamescom.
Einfach,
weil es da nichts Spannendes mehr gibt.
Die Infos kriegst du,
wenn du nicht auf der Gamescom bist, sogar besser.
Außerdem
ist Gamescom,
soll ich sagen,
unnötig,
anstrengend und
Beine im Bauch gestehe.
Mache ich schon seit Jahren nicht mehr.
Und wir hatten ja noch die bessere Variante.
Wir haben uns ja da immer im Vorfeld
akkreditiert.
Wir hatten auch ein bisschen was, wo man sein Gepäck
abstellen kann und
dann zurücklaufen konnte
und sich mal ganz kurz hinsetzen und sowas.
Aber...
Ne, habe ich keinen Bock mehr.
Mittlerweile ist Gamescom eher
Influencer-Meet & Greet, ja.
Oder von Montana Black Bodyguards
umgerannt werden. Da gab es doch vor ein paar Jahren...
Da gab es doch vor ein paar Jahren
so einen Typ, der sich beschwert hat.
Der ist den ganzen Tag immer Montana Black
nachgerannt und
irgendwann stand er mal im Weg, der hat ihn in den Bodyguard
weggeschubst. Da gab es doch einen riesen Aufschrei
vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum man auf die Gamescom
geht und dann irgendwelche Influencers
chasen will den ganzen Tag.
Gerade wenn du ein bisschen größer und bekannter
bist, du kannst dich ja da überhaupt nicht frei
mehr bewegen. Was?
Wen?
Ach du meinst, da fehlt ein N?
Da fehlt ein N.
Naja, ist nicht wirklich,
dass wir uns irgendwie gut kennen würden oder so.
Naja.
Ich muss ehrlich gesagt von YouTube gar
kein treffen. Habe ich keinen Bock
drauf. Die Leute, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe,
verstanden habe, mit denen habe ich teilweise
noch ein bisschen Kontakt.
Mit denen würde ich mich dann treffen, aber
nicht unbedingt auf der Gamescom.
Jetzt haben wir uns ein wenig
sidetracken lassen
von der Frage, die
weiß nicht, wer die
ursprünglich gestellt hat.
Ach ja,
mit Rust, ja. Also ein bisschen
schon, wobei es bei mir nicht Rust ist,
was mich dazu gebracht hat, manche
Sachen anders zu sehen. Oder nicht unbedingt
Rust an sich, sondern
allgemein so die,
den etwas mehr funktionaleren
Einschlag, den
viele moderneren
Sprachen haben, ja. Guckt euch Kotlin
an, guckt euch Rust an, guckt euch
die letzten Erinnerungen von C Sharp an, die letzten Jahre,
man sieht eindeutig, vieles
schlägt so ein bisschen in die
funktionale
Richtung. Und da sind schon ein paar
ganz gute Sachen dabei.
Aber soviel jetzt hier zu C Sharp und Rust
und Proggas, Proggas, Stelz.
Ja.
Gut.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir mit euch die,
was hatten die hier denn noch, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch schnell
fertig an,
IT an. Sollte ich mir das angucken
oder warum hat mir das jemand geschickt, ich weiß
es gar nicht. Also zumindest
haben die den Obstkorb, die sind schon mal nice.
Also Hannover,
okay. Also was haben die denn hier? Deine
Aufgaben, Optimierung und Entwicklung unserer hybriden
IT-Infrastruktur. Das ist übrigens auch ein neues,
so neu ist es nicht, aber wird zurzeit
gerne benutzt.
Hybrid, Hybrid
Infrastructure.
Damit ist eigentlich nur gemeint, dass
man Sachen, ich sag's jetzt mal
wie es die Noobs sagen würden, dass man Sachen
bei sich im Rechenzentrum stehen hat und
Sachen in der Cloud stehen hat.
Korrekterweise mit Buzzwords müsste
man das heute nennen, dass man Sachen auch
on Prem stehen hat und
in Kombination mit Hyperscalern.
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, was
versteht ihr besser? Dass man
Sachen on Prem stehen hat in Kombination
mit Hyperscalern versus
man hat auch noch Sachen stehen im eigenen
Rechenzentrum und in der Cloud.
Wo man wieder sieht,
Sachen möglichst Buzzword
geschmückt, sorgt nicht unbedingt
für besseres Verständnis.
On Prem und Cloud. Na wenn schon
dann Hyperscaler, weil die coolen Leute
sagen Hyperscaler heute zu Cloud
Anbietern.
Kennst du den Begriff Anypremise?
Ne.
Ich kann mir da was zusammen reiben,
so nach dem Motto, es ist egal wo das steht.
Es kann in der Cloud
sein, es kann lokal sein, es muss dich nicht
interessieren.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das damit gemeint ist, aber
das habe ich noch nicht gehört. Das klingt wie
irgendwas aus, keine Ahnung, Oracle SAP
Umfeld. Die haben immer so geile Begriffe.
Nochmal Anypremise.
Ha!
Ich wusste es, Leute!
Ich wusste es, Alter!
War klar, Mann!
Meine Intuition
hat richtig gelegen.
War klar, dass das irgendwie Oracle oder SAP
Shit sein muss.
Ihr habt euren Hyperscaler On Prem.
Weißt du was, Alfred?
Das wäre
eine super nice
Vorstellungsgesprächsfrage.
Um zu checken, ob die Leute wissen.
Also mal angenommen,
jemand erzählt mir was im Vorstellungsgespräch
von Hyperscalern
und On Prem und Skalierung
und sonst was.
Und dann könntest du
ihn mal fragen, was halten sie davon
den Hyperscaler On Prem zu betreiben?
Da bin ich gespannt, was er sagt.
Wenn er weiß, was er sagt, wird er sagen, äh
wie, das passt nicht zusammen.
Entweder Cloud oder lokal.
Aber wenn er einfach nur Buzzword Bingo
spielt, ohne Ahnung davon zu haben,
was er eigentlich sagt,
dann wird er antworten so,
ja, das ist auch eine Überlegung wert.
Oder so.
Eigentlich ist es eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Das ist echt eine gute
Vorstellungsgesprächsfrage.
Okay, also was haben die hier denn?
Wo haben wir es denn?
Man kümmert sich um
vor allem wäre NetApp.
Docker?
Docker passt da so überhaupt nicht rein
in diese Aufzählung.
Virtualisierungsplattform,
Storage-Plattform,
Cloud-Anbieter,
Bullshit-Anbieter
und dann Container
CLI.
Hä?
Planung und
Koordinierung eigenverantwortlicher
IT-Projekte. Ah, okay, Moment.
Ich dachte, du bist ein Admin. Du bist auch noch ein
Projektmanager. Okay, alles klar.
Integration von Hard- und Softwarekomponenten
bestehende Sicherstellung der Datensicherheit,
Implementierung von Backup-Strategien.
Okay.
Ja, alles klar.
Unterstützung der Anwender-Beihilfe. Ach, komm.
Ach, komm. Muss das wirklich sein?
Muss das wirklich sein?
Bisher hätte ich ja gesagt, okay,
vielleicht nicht verkehrt, aber
jetzt, ey.
Endanwender-Support.
MomKS.
Dokumentation.
Schon wieder, Leute.
Schon wieder nicht.
Wubblos-Certified-Arbeitgeber.
Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Wer
Sachen bereitstellt, die
einfach first try
funktionieren, braucht es nicht
dokumentieren. Einfach
keine Fehler machen.
Wisst ihr, wie viel Geld man spart damit,
dass man keine Fehler macht?
Du brauchst weniger Leute. Du brauchst keine
Dokumentation. Du brauchst keine Kommentare.
Du brauchst kein Backup.
Also alles sparen. Einfach
nichts falsch machen.
Das sage ich dir schon seit Jahren im Stream.
Ich sollte echt mal ein
Kart rausbringen.
Das ist das High-Performer, High-IQ
Mindset.
Und das spart auch noch Zeit.
Du musst danach nichts mehr fixen
und sowas.
Fundierte Kenntnisse, Server, Netzwerk,
Virtualisierung,
Sicherheit, Datenschutz,
Orchestrierung und den Betrieb von
Docker-basierten Systemen. Du bist ein
Teamplayer, motiviert dich permanent weiterzuentwickeln.
Aber was macht der Nachfolger bei der alten Firma
so? Nichts, weil das System hier einfach
funktioniert.
Es läuft einfach weiter.
Ich habe vergessen, wo wir sind hier.
Warum wir? Flexible Arbeitsoptionales
Homeoffice. So, so.
Das klingt schon sehr vage,
so nach dem Motto, ja, vielleicht,
wenn du Glück hast, darfst du einmal im Monat.
30 Urlaubstage ist auch
ziemlich normal. Außer bei,
wo hatten wir das letztens, wo einer mit 24
Urlaubstagen um die Ecke gekommen ist?
Onboarding-Programm. Da kann ich immer nur
dazu sagen,
ich finde, es ist das ureigenste
Interesse des Arbeitgebers, die Leute
gescheit zu onboarden und gescheit
einzuarbeiten, damit sie was für ihr
Geld bekommen. Ganz ehrlich,
Leute einstellen
und sie eben nicht ordentlich
einführen in das Unternehmen,
ist
rausgeschmissenes Geld, unterm Strich.
Also alle Unternehmen, die das so
machen, sind einfach nur dumm.
Dann hast du jemanden da sitzen, der
am ersten Tag keine Ausstattung hat,
keine Accounts hat, keinen, der ihm was
zeigen kann, der sitzt einfach seine
Zeit ab und
verdient Geld. Also Leute,
nicht einarbeiten ist einfach nur Geld
zum Fenster rausgeschmissen.
Ich weiß, dass das oft genug
nicht passiert, aber es ist
jetzt mal ehrlich, Leute, oder seht ihr das
anders? Du kannst nichts machen,
ohne eingearbeitet zu werden. Das heißt,
du kostest Geld, ohne dass du was bringst.
Ja, ich verstehe unter Onboarding,
Onboarding ist für mich
der neue Begriff für
Einarbeitung. Also,
dass du nicht nur
Einarbeitung, was fachliche Themen angeht,
sondern auch Einarbeitung, so wie
sind spezielle Workflows in der Firma,
wie beantragst du Wartungsarbeiten,
wie beantragst du Urlaub, wie
machst du Zeiterfassung,
wann
musst du da und da wem Bescheid
sagen und sowas. Das gehört ja alles zu
Einarbeitung und Onboarding mit dabei.
Du hast einen Account, wenn du dort am ersten
Arbeitstag erscheinst. Du bekommst dein
Passwort, du bekommst dein Handy, du bekommst
dein Laptop, du bekommst deinen Schlüssel
für den Spind und sowas.
Das ist im ureigensten
Interesse der Firma, dass
derjenige, den du ab dem ersten Tag
bezahlen musst, auch was machen kann.
Und das kann ja durchaus fachlich
rein ins Getümmel sein, aber du musst trotzdem
eingearbeitet und onboardet werden.
Und Unternehmen,
die das nicht machen, die schmeißen Geld
zum Fenster raus.
Die machen Pepo Burn Money, Leute.
Pepo Burn
Money machen die.
Das hier. Die werden es nicht
direkt merken,
aber letztendlich ist es
Pepo Burn Money.
Alter, wo ist diese?
Ja, es ist auch sinnvoll.
Man muss sich das nicht immer neu aus den
Fingern saugen,
wenn jemand anfängt. Es ist
sogar gut für beide Seiten, wenn man schon
einen gewissen
Step-by-Step
Guide hat.
Dann muss man sich selbst das nicht immer aus den
Fingern saugen. Und für die neuen Leute ist es auch gut,
da können die mal nachgucken. Das finde ich sehr sinnvoll,
sowas.
Jep, Glock.
So, sonst steht da eigentlich nichts
Spannendes mehr drin.
Bonusprogramm für
Mitarbeiterempfehlungen. Ey, da muss ich
meinen aktuellen Arbeitgeber mal loben.
Ich habe jemand empfohlen
für eine andere
Position,
noch bevor ich dort selbst angefangen habe.
Und ich habe trotzdem
den Bonus bekommen
für Mitarbeiterempfehlungen.
Also da muss ich sagen, Hut ab
vor der Personalabteilung, wie sie das
bürokratisch gemanagt haben.
Ich habe ja
an dem Tag, wo ich mein Vorstellungsgespräch
hatte,
bei der Versicherung in Frankfurt,
da war ich fertig mit dem Vorstellungsgespräch,
wir haben uns gut verstanden, haben uns
darauf verständigt, jawoll, passt, wir wollen
beide. Da hatte ich die
Bewerbungsunterlagen von einem Kollege dabei und habe
gesagt, ich habe gesehen auf eurer
Homepage, ihr sucht noch jemand,
so eine ähnliche Position, ich kenne da
jemand. Und habe ihm das
in die Hand gedrückt, paar Tage
später haben sie sich bei dem anderen gemeldet
und er arbeitet heute auch da.
Und ich habe den Bonus für das
Werben dieses Mitarbeiters bekommen.
Obwohl ich zum Zeitpunkt der Werbung
noch nicht dort
gearbeitet habe. Also das
haben sie gut hingekriegt in der Personalabteilung.
Muss man sagen.
Ok.
Ok, ja, 0815 Schnellanzeige
gibt es jetzt eigentlich nichts, weder
positives noch negatives
drüber zu berichten, ist sehr 0815.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sich da
viele darauf bewerben werden.
Wirkt irgendwie sehr,
weiß nicht, generic.
So,
dann, nach
1 Stunde 50 Sidetracken,
kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen
Geschichte zurück. Github
Trends, wie sieht es denn, was macht
denn eigentlich der Fiat Champ? Alles Anwendungsfehler.
App running calls
to API working, but
no data coming through. Oh fuck, Alter.
Ja, alles Anwendungsfehler.
Der Fiat Champ
ist ja auch Wubbler certified.
Das heißt, der funktioniert einfach immer first try,
wie man hier sieht. Oh Leute, ich müsste
unbedingt dran weitermachen.
Ich habe
eigentlich Bock, aber auch wieder nicht.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Fuck.
Github Trends.
Pass auf, im Source soll sie
flicken. Genau.
Moment, wie gucken wir
immer? Github Trends? Hier gucken wir
immer.
Was trendet auf Github?
Aha! Blazingly
fast, written in rust.
A friendly language for building
type-safe scalable systems.
Okay, ich habe jetzt die
Projektbezeichnung gelesen, ich habe
aber immer noch keine
Ahnung, was
es ist.
Aber da steht das
was in rust ist.
Es ist in R lang.
Fake.
Alter.
Rust bait.
You got to bait it.
Es ist überhaupt nicht rust.
Aber es ist
ergeblich 93%.
93% rust, 0,3%
R lang?
What?
Es ist rust. Es ist sehr viel rust.
Es ist kaum was R lang, oder?
Okay, whatever.
Ich habe aber
keine Ahnung, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Es hat ein niedliches
Logo.
Leicht cutes
Das gefällt mir, das ist nice.
Monka W.
Was ist das?
Das hat ja schon fast was von Lisp, so ein bisschen.
Wobei, nee, Lisp hätte noch ein bisschen
mehr.
Das ist gültiger Lisp-Code hier gerade.
Was ist das?
Ich vermute, dass das so eine Art
Link-Query ist.
Also, du erstellst quasi
eine Liste
mit Zahlen zwischen
ich weiß nicht, ob inclusive, exclusive
zwischen 0 und 200.000.
Dann pipst du
diese Liste, genau, Chat,
quasi nach Map, das Ergebnis
nach Each. Also, das ist so was
wie Link, würde ich sagen.
Aber diese
Analyzer ist
Paints-Champ.
Okay, irgendwas, was ich nicht brauche, glaube ich.
So, dann gibt es
Frontend-Zeug.
Es gibt ein Rust-
Bundler für JavaScript.
Vermutlich ist das ein weiteres
Projekt der Kategorie
Rust
Community löst Probleme,
die es nicht gibt.
Wenn es Rollup-kompatibel ist,
ist es auch Vite-kompatibel.
Ah ja.
Sehr schön. Dann bin ich dafür.
Vite is nice.
Du hast aber,
du hast aber viel Geduld.
Zwei Jahre. Zwei Jahre ist
in JavaScript so wie
20 Jahre bei uns.
Zwei Jahre, das ist wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich gibt es schon
fünf Alternativ-Projekte.
So, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Moment.
Die China-Chinesen-Firewall
für Linux. Was?
Oder ist das einfach nur ein Proxy?
OpenGFW is a flexible, easy to use
open source implementation of
Great Firewall of China on Linux.
What?
Very own
do-it-yourself Great Firewall of China.
But why?
Gekommeritz approved.
Mit Kernel-Modulen
und sonst was. Written in
Go.
Okay.
Ja, sowas in Rust zu machen ist
wahrscheinlich eine Lebensaufgabe.
Fabric.
AI-Zeug.
Daytona,
the open source dev
environment manager.
Was
ist das?
Open source development
environment manager.
Ist das quasi
Docker-Container
mit Zeug, oder?
Single command
activated fully.
Hä?
So richtig checken
tue ich's noch nicht?
Hä?
Ich verstehe nicht, was das macht.
Also, ich sehe es, aber
ich hätte doch einfach auch sagen können
.NET new bla bla bla
project, oder
NPM
creates world project, oder so.
Warum muss ich das
über Starlight machen?
Okay, es ist ein Remote Server dahinter,
wo er sich dann hinkonnectet, aber ich kann das
auch auf einen Remote Server machen.
Hä?
Okay, das ist vielleicht was, wenn man es mal benutzt hat,
checkt man besser, wo der...
Okay, das ist quasi Postman.
Oh ne, oh ne, please!
Warum trennen Elektron?
No, God!
No, God,
please, no!
Ach, eigentlich, eigentlich ist es mir egal, was Elektron
macht. Elektron ist okay.
Für das, was es ist.
Ich meine, wir haben immerhin
Visual Studio Code haben wir Elektron zu verdanken,
und auch ein paar andere Sachen. Also,
ist okay, dass es da drinsteht.
Ist mir egal, ist mir egal, dass es drinsteht.
Egal!
Passt jetzt einfach mal ganz gut.
Windows in Docker Container...
Ja, was kein Windows in Docker
Container ist, sondern
KVM passt through in Docker Container,
wo dann Windows drinnen läuft.
Build like a team
of hundreds underscores.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen,
das kommt mir bekannt vor. Ich weiß aber aus dem Kopf
nicht mal, was das ist. Ist das
ein CI-Server, oder was? Nee.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Ich checke aber gerade nicht,
was es ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist BaaS.
Okay, okay.
Was ist BaaS?
Es ist Service, ja.
Aber wie?
Backend
as a Service.
Ich überlege gerade, was ist Backend as a Service?
Also ein GraphQL Endpunkt zu einer Datenbank
oder sowas. Ach so!
Sowas wie Firebase.
Ah, ja, ja. Okay, okay.
Nennt man sowas heutzutage Backend as a Service?
Okay, das ist mir auch neu.
Das wusste ich noch nicht.
Was ist das?
The Internet OS.
Okay, cooles Projekt,
sowas im Browser laufen zu bekommen.
Die Sache ist nur,
warum?
Also warum?
Weshalb?
Wann verwendet man sowas?
ManDoctor.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie lange das jetzt gebraucht hat,
zu starten?
BashTruid hat resubscribed.
Danke für den Sub. Habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Pog.
Für Schulung?
Aber warum?
Mir fällt echt
kein Anwendungszweck ein, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist Paint quasi.
Terminal.
Cranker. Jawoll.
Was läuft da drin?
Markus.
Ist das nicht ein Stuhl von Ikea?
Mir fehlt jetzt hier noch ein Browser, oder?
Browser wär doch nice.
Quasi nen Browser
im Browser zu haben.
Das kann Doom, garantiert.
Und dann im Browser
das nochmal öffnen.
Das ist bestimmt
ein super cooles
Achievement,
sowas zu programmieren. Aber der
Sinn erschließt sich mir nicht.
Na gut.
Open Sora.
AI. AI.
AI. AI. AI. AI.
Keine Ahnung, ob das
AI ist.
AI.
Diese Woche war ja das ein oder andere
dabei, wo ich mal drauf geklickt hab.
Kommt mir selten vor.
Es wurde gemacht, um WebGPU
zu testen. Das kann natürlich sein.
Ja, das kann
tatsächlich sein. Ja.
So, was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Ich wollte mir das...
MonkaS.
Ich wollte mir das Video hier tatsächlich angucken,
weil ich ja schon lange überlege,
ob ich nicht
den Kabelanschluss
abbestellen soll. Also für
für Fernseher
oder von Internet würde ich behalten.
Weil ich benutze
den nicht.
Meine Mutter benutzt den.
Ich benutze den nicht.
Und...
Ich bin der Meinung,
die könnte auch ohne Probleme mit hier irgendwie so was
anderem gucken.
So damit zum Beispiel.
Aber die ist sehr
sag mal
oldschool,
was das angeht.
Und die kommt damit
dann wahrscheinlich nicht klar.
Ist das dann
günstiger?
Wahrscheinlich nicht viel.
Aber...
Man bräuchte
einige Sachen nicht.
Ja, man bräuchte zum Beispiel
nicht diese Kiste mit den TV-Tunern
drinne.
Ich bräuchte hier...
Ja, also...
Aber ein Ding ist halt, also
warum...
Also ich hab mir Satu und Viper
und so auch schon angeguckt.
Was mir da dran nicht gefällt ist, dass du bist
halt komplett
auf die App
von denen angewiesen.
Also...
Streams schauen mit irgendwas anderem
ist nur super komplizierte
Zwischenhacks möglich.
Und...
Dementsprechend kannst du halt auch nix aufnehmen.
Die nimmt...
Die nimmt gerne Sendungen auf. Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Ja?
Die könnte die ganzen Sachen auch ohne Probleme
in der ZDF ARD Mediathek
oder sowas gucken. Aber nein,
die nimmt immer zig, zig Dinge auf.
Das ist die halt seit, keine Ahnung,
40 Jahren gewöhnt.
Was man mit dem Fernseher so machen kann.
Die hatte ja früher noch so'n Videorekorder mit Kassetten.
Falls den, falls den Kram überhaupt noch jemand kennt.
Die nimmt sich dann immer Tatort
und so'n Shit auf.
Letztens mal reingeguckt in die Fernsehaufnahmen.
Alter, was da drinne ist, man.
Tatort, äh...
Nicht Rosamunde Pilcher,
aber sowas in der Richtung.
Könnt ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Aber okay.
Dementsprechend wär's cool, wenn ich das Kabel
Fernseh loswerde, aber...
Ich glaube,
dass das nicht so richtig
gut ersetzt werden kann
durch die Apps.
Durch Internetservices.
Okay,
aber deswegen, das wollte ich mir angucken,
das Video. Ist mir vorhin schon ins Auge gesprungen.
Deswegen gucken wir uns das mal an.
Ich zappe hier so richtig oldschool durch die Fernsehkanäle.
Und dabei ist mein Fernseher
weder über ne Satellitenschüssel noch über Kabel
oder irgendwie sonst an den klassischen
Fernsehempfang angeschlossen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt fragt...
Was ich mir auch schon überlegt hab, ist,
die guckt ja zum größten Teil öffentlich-rechtliche
Sender.
Die sind ja eigentlich public im Internet verfügbar.
Da hab ich mir
auch schon überlegt,
es gibt ja so Listen,
die immer wieder
so Playlisten, die immer wieder
aktualisiert werden und die neuesten Streamlinks
drinne haben zu allen öffentlich-rechtlichen.
Ob ich das in TV Headend einbinde,
weil ich sie gerade sehe.
Da könnte sie nämlich weiterhin gucken,
wie bisher, weil aktuell
läuft das so.
Ich hab eine Tuner-Box.
Die hat
Linux drauf.
Das ist so eine hier.
VU plus 4K
oder so.
So ein Teil ist das.
Da läuft Linux drauf.
Haben wir selbst im Stream Sachen für kompiliert.
Da läuft
Linux mit TV Headend drauf.
Das Ding ist halt
nice, weil da hast du 8 Tuner.
Da kannst du beliebig viel gucken und
anschauen und so, was du willst.
Gleichzeitig und aufnehmen.
Da läuft Linux drauf
mit TV Headend.
Und am Fernseher ist
ein Shield TV
und auf dem Shield TV
ist Kodi drauf
mit dem TV Headend Client.
Würde nicht
DVB-T reichen.
Da brauchst du ja auch eine gescheite Antenne für,
dass das gut funktioniert.
Und außerdem ist DVB-T ruckelig teilweise
lahm im switchen.
Ja, aber
noch eine zweite Sache habe ich
keinen Bock drauf.
Das funktioniert echt ganz gut.
Die Kiste ist
wirklich zuverlässiger Tuner.
Allerdings war die Kiste mit der
Standard-Firmware kompletter Schrott.
Mit TV Headend drauf ist die
aber gut.
Und da ist halt auch eine SSD
drin.
Wo man die Fernsehaufnahmen
drauf speichern kann.
Und auf dem Shield TV
läuft
Kodi mit dem TV Headend Client
greift da drauf zu.
Und das funktioniert relativ problemlos.
Ab und zu musst du mal Kodi neu starten,
weil es sich verschluckt.
Aber an sich kein Ding.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Und wenn ich das jetzt umstellen würde auf IPTV
gibt es kein gescheites Kodi Addon
dafür,
was Aufnahmen unterstützt. Die Festplatte müsste
irgendwie an Shield TV dran, das ist kacke.
Also funzt auch nicht richtig.
Ich glaube, ich lasse mein Setup so.
Warum ein Setup ändern,
was einfach gut funktioniert?
Gucken wir mal, was die Alternativen
so machen.
Normales lineares Fernsehen?
Es reicht doch das hier.
Oder andere Streaming-Anbieter.
Dann sag ich euch, es gibt auf jeden Fall Momente,
bei denen echtes Fernsehen super ist.
Und zumindest,
was ich jetzt noch sagen will,
wenn ich das IPTV-mäßig
machen könnte, dann könnte ich die Box hier
halt wegschmeißen.
Oder wegmachen.
Und das würde ich dann hier auf meinen HP-Server
draufpacken.
TV-Header für IPTV.
Jetzt hätten wir eine Kiste
weniger im Wohnzimmer stehen.
Aber ansonsten...
Aber mal gucken, ob die was taugen.
Bin echt gespannt.
Ich hab das mal angeguckt vor einer ganzen Weile
und da hat es mich nicht so überzeugt.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Momente,
bei denen echtes Fernsehen super ist.
Bei Live-Veranstaltungen zum Beispiel,
also bei jeder beliebigen Sportart.
Alter, der flippt ja mal voll aus.
Eurovision Song Contest oder viele andere große Events.
Wenn man sowas gucken will,
dann macht das Live viel mehr Spaß.
Bei manchen dieser Sachen
gibt es zwar auch einen Livestream im Internet,
bei manchen aber auch nicht.
Ja, und bislang lief bei den meisten Leuten einfach...
Ja, Fußball ist ja eh so ein komplettes Ding,
der Unmöglichkeit, oder?
Wenn man das alles gucken will.
Was brauchst du denn...
Leute, ich bin kein Fußball-Gucker,
aber was brauchst du denn mittlerweile,
um die Sachen alle gucken zu können?
Du brauchst Dutzen
und du brauchst Sky, ja?
Ich glaube, so ist das.
Und manches läuft, glaube ich, auch in ARD und ZDF.
Kann das sein?
Also, das ist, glaube ich, ultra teuer.
Es ist eh teilweise richtig, richtig blöd,
wie krass du da überall zur Karte kommst.
Ja.
Wenn du in die Kasse gebeten wirst...
Ich wollte letztes Jahr
ein bisschen Tour de France schauen
und das ging.
Früher
konntest du das ohne Probleme gucken
über
entweder eine ARD
oder über Eurosport.
So, Eurosport gibt es nicht mehr so zu empfangen
und
die ARD
bringt ganz wenig nur noch.
Und
du könntest zwar streamen im Internet,
nee,
das kommt nur noch ganz, ganz kurz
und auch nicht alle Etappen.
Also,
da musst du schon Glück haben.
Zumindest die, also ARD
hatte früher mal ein
Stream,
wo die das begleitet haben im Internet.
Den haben sie jetzt aber auch nicht mehr.
Fußball schauen war noch, meines Wissens nach,
nie gratis, nur bei den größeren internationalen Events.
Also,
das kannst du knicken.
Ja, aber da wird es nicht mehr übertragen.
Ich habe es letztes, ich habe es letztes probiert.
Die wollten mir immer ihre App aufschwätzen.
So, und was ich letztes, was ich letztes
Jahr gemacht habe, ist, ich habe...
Ich glaube, das war auch,
weil mir die Kommentatoren in der ARD so auf den Sack
gegangen sind.
Ich habe übers Internet gestreamt, geguckt
von irgendeinem britischen
Sender.
Und wenn du bei denen
auf die Webseite gehst,
dann sagen die, ah, außerhalb
ihres Landes, da kann man da
nicht streamen und hier und da.
Und
dann habe ich halt ein VPN aufgebaut.
Und habe da drüber
geguckt.
Das war auch viel angenehmer.
Ja, ich muss sagen, Radsport, und nicht,
weil ich jetzt seit neuestem selbst wieder ein bisschen Fahrrad
fahre. Radsport ist eines der wenigen
Sachen, die ich schon wirklich lange
immer mal wieder ein bisschen verfolge.
Das liegt auch daran,
weil das, sagen wir mal, könnte
sagen, weil das langweilig ist,
bis auf manche Abschnitte.
Ich finde das super entspannend
zum nebenbei laufen lassen.
Und dann mal gucken, wenn was passiert.
Klar, man hat so ein bisschen seine Favoriten und so,
wo man will, dass die gut mitfahren.
Aber ich gucke auch so zwischendurch
mal ein bisschen und gucke mir die Ergebnisse an.
Ansonsten
interessiert mich eigentlich so gut wie nix.
Also mal E-Sport außen vor.
Aber vom klassischen Sport an, mich interessiert
weder Fußball, noch Eishockey, noch sonst was.
Also Radsport verfolge ich auch.
So ein bisschen, was da an Transfers
abgeht und wie
welche Teams wo antreten und sowas.
So nebenbei ist
nicht so, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie
der super informierte
Allesgucker wäre.
Biathlon habe ich früher gerne
mit meinem Opa geguckt.
Das war aber nicht so sehr wegen Biathlon,
sondern weil ich es mit meinem Opa geguckt habe.
Und es war auch teilweise sehr spannend,
weil, ich weiß nicht wie es heute ist,
Deutschland war früher
in Biathlon mega gut.
Aber früher waren die richtig gut.
Die Norweger, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Norweger waren auch richtig krass.
Norweger
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich Schweizer.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Norweger, Schweizer, Deutsche.
Wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, Alter warum sind wir
so gut? Warum sind wir so gut
in Biathlon? Wir waren richtig
krass früher in Biathlon. Ich weiß nicht wie es heute ist.
Okay, so. Jetzt gucken wir aber mal
das Video. Wir haben mal Zeit.
So ein Kabelanschluss mit.
Das ist ja bei vielen von euch sowieso
in der Mietwohnung vorhanden und bezahlen
muss man dann über die Miete sowieso dafür.
Über die Nebenkosten.
Ist es nicht so, dass es jetzt nicht mehr so ist?
War da nicht was? Habe ich nicht letztens was von Kabelanschluss
und Miete, irgendwas gelesen,
dass sich da jetzt irgendwas geändert hat?
Kabelanschluss
ist da nicht.
Achso, deswegen das Video. Okay.
Ah!
Ich hätte vielleicht mal eine Sekunde weitergucken müssen.
Nämlich keinen Kabelanschluss
mehr für das ganze Haus buchen.
Du musst dir jetzt entweder selbst einen TV-Vertrag
organisieren oder einen
von den ganzen...
Finde ich aber eigentlich gut. Chat,
sollen wir das gut finden oder schlecht finden,
dass das jetzt nicht mehr so ist?
Für mich klingt es erstmal gut, weil da muss ich den Shit
nicht mitbezahlen, wenn ich gar keinen Fernseher gucken will.
Klingt für mich jetzt erstmal nicht verkehrt.
Aber für die, die es machen wollen,
ist es wahrscheinlich teurer.
waifu.tv
Boah, das gibt es wahrscheinlich auch noch.
Diese haben nicht nur mehr Funktionen, sondern sind
auch deutlich flexibler, weil du zum Beispiel
auch von überall aus auf deinem Smartphone
live schauen kannst oder direkt in der
Cloud das TV-Programm aufzeichnen.
Was es da alles gibt und
worauf ihr dabei achten solltet und
ob es da auch eine Linux-Homeserver-Lösung
gibt, das erfahrt ihr alles in diesem Video.
Bleibt dran.
Das sind Träumer, Mann.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Nowall.
Ich habe zwar kein Haustier, aber
ich haare wie so ein Haustier.
Aber ich habe
keinen Staubsauger-Roboter mehr.
Ich hatte zwei
und ich benutze keinen mehr davon.
Ich hatte als erstes so einen komplett
braindead Eufy, der einfach nur immer
gegen die Wand gefahren ist, sich gedreht hat,
gegen die Wand gefahren ist, sich gedreht hat
und dann irgendwann mal damit so den ganzen
Raum erwischt hat. Danach hatte ich
einen Roborock S5
mit geflashter Custom-Firmware,
der eigentlich mega nice
gewesen ist, weil du den schönen
System einbinden konntest und ein
Web-Interface hattest und war eigentlich
sehr cool.
Hatte einen Bug, dass sich manchmal das ganze
resetet hat, aber selbst
das hat mich nicht davon abgehalten,
da monatelang rumzubasteln und zu flashen
und zu machen. Wunderbar.
Dumm ist nur,
dass ich
es mittlerweile überflüssig finde.
Weil das ist
kein Staubsauger-Roboter mit einer
Entleerstation. Heißt im Endeffekt,
jedes Mal,
muss das Ding
rausholen, rumdrehen,
leermachen,
wegschmeißen, hinstellen.
Und ganz ehrlich, das Ding braucht
so lang, bis das hier oben durch hat,
dann schnapp ich mir lieber
den Staubsauger, den ganz klassischen
0815 Staubsauger
und flitz einmal mal
durch den Flur hier durch und einmal mal
durch irgendwie das Arbeitszimmer durch
und gut ist. Ich weiß, dass es
komplett automatische gibt.
Mehrstöckig, na gut,
mehrstöckig bräuchtest du einfach zwei.
Einen oben, einen unten.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde es
mittlerweile überflüssig. Ihr wisst,
ich stehe unglaublich auf Smart Home Sachen
und spiele rein und gebastel,
aber nur, wenn ich irgendwie
auch einen gewissen Vorteil
oder ja, wie nennt man das,
Quality of Life Improvement
dadurch sehe und
das war eher umgedreht. Ich muss
ehrlich sagen, ich finde es
überflüssig, Staubsauger-Roboter.
Der Frio X Ultra Staubsauger-Roboter
mit Wischfunktion für mich
ganz gut geeignet. Der hat nämlich eine
Anti-Verhedderungsbürste,
die ist TÜV und SGS
zertifiziert und erfasst laut
Nahwahl 99,56%
aller Haare.
Und dazu bekommt man 0%
Haarverhedderung. Das
Verhedderungsproblem kennt man ja von anderen
Staubsauger-Robotern und das soll mit
Nahwahl jetzt vorbei sein. Außerdem bietet der
Nahwahl Frio X Ultra mit
8200 Pascal die
höchste Saugleistung aller aktuellen
Geräte. Statt mit so einer
riesig großen Aufladestation
Gut, dass wir das jetzt wissen. ist der Frio X
angenehm klein. Möglich ist das, weil
die Station keinen Staubbehälter hat.
Stattdessen wird der Staub im Roboter
selbst gelagert. Durch Pressen wird
ermöglicht, dass man bis zu 7 Wochen lang nicht
entleeren muss.
Kommt drauf an, wie viel Staub du hast. Ist der
1 Liter Einwegbeutel voll, wirft man ihn
einfach in die Mülltonne. Der
Frio X Ultra hat einen Wasseranschluss.
Nutzt man den, wird das Wasser automatisch
getauscht. Hatte meiner auch.
Ich hab's nie verwendet.
Man muss also gar nicht mehr selbst eingreifen.
Last not least, der
Nahwahl-Roboter erkennt selbstständig
Schmutz und wischt dann entsprechend
mit den zwei drehenden Dreiecksmops
nach, die mit 12
Newton auf den Boden gedrückt werden.
Falls ihr mehr über den Frio X Ultra
wissen wollt, klickt auf den Link unten in
der Beschreibung. Ansonsten könnt ihr auch
einfach Nahwahl Frio X Ultra
auf Google oder Amazon suchen.
Werbung Ende.
Darüber, wie nervig Streaming
mit Prime, Netflix und Co sein kann,
da haben wir ja schon vor zwei Jahren...
Ja, kann es.
Es kann übelst abfucken, vor allem
wenn Amazon jetzt noch mit Werbung um die Ecke
kommt.
Und ja, einiges ist in der
Zwischenzeit besser geworden, aber
ein Problem bleibt auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt nämlich ein Überangriff.
Wisst ihr, wozu das geführt hat?
Dass du immer mehr Streaminganbieter
brauchst und dass
die Streaminganbieter, bei denen du bist, dich
anfangen immer mehr abzufacken?
Wisst ihr, wozu das bei mir geführt hat?
Das führt dazu, dass
ich tatsächlich vermehrt
Animes geschaut habe in letzter Zeit.
Obwohl ich früher nie welche geguckt
habe. Mal vereinzelt, aber nicht viele.
Piratenflagge
nee, aber die kannst du kostenlos
im Internet gucken.
Ich mein,
das ist vielleicht auch nur Grauzonen legal?
Netflix Prime Autoskip.
Ah, nice, nice.
Funstwahrscheinlich in der App nicht richtig, gell?
Und nachdem ich nie großartig
Animes geguckt hab,
hab ich auch mehr als genug gescheite
Sachen, die ich noch nicht gesehen hab,
die ich gucken kann. Ja, dann kommt
Netflix, die das nicht mehr erlauben,
dass du's sharest und sowas. Richtig für'n Arsch
alles.
Ich weiß manchmal echt nicht, was ich gucken soll, weil es einfach
zu viel Auswahl gibt. Klar, das ist ein Luxusproblem,
aber das kenn... Was schaust du?
Also, was ich gerade geguckt hab, ist die erste
Staffel von...
Oh, wie hieß das nochmal genau?
Reincarnated as a Slime?
Oder sowas?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie das
genau hieß.
Es ist kein
Gachi-Bass-Zeug, ja?
Was ganz normales.
Autopiracy-Stream?
Nee.
Einige von euch bestimmt auch. Und das ist wahrscheinlich
einer der letzten Strohhalme, an denen
sich das klassische Fernsehen klammert.
Einfach überforderte, verirrte
Seelen auf der Couch einfangen,
die noch kein TikTok auf ihrem Handy haben.
Nee, aber jetzt mal im Ernst.
Bisher war das in Mietwohnungen so, dass
die Vermieter für das ganze Haus einen Vertrag
mit dem Kabelanbieter
abgeschlossen haben. Und die Kosten dafür
haben die Mieter dann in der Nebenkostenabrechnung
bekommen. Das heißt, du hast für den Anschluss
bezahlt, egal ob du den benutzt hast
oder nicht. Das war ein Privileg,
das schon seit den 1980er Jahren
besteht und ursprünglich mal dem Ausbau
des Kabelnetzes helfen sollte.
Findet ihr das absurd? Dann googelt
mal Schaumweinsteuer.
Die Schaumweinsteuer wurde 1902
vom Reichstag zur Finanzierung
der kaiserlichen
Kriegsflotte eingeführt, weil bei einer
so starken Steigerung
der Ausgaben für die Wehrkraft
des Landes auch der Schaumwein
herangezogen
werden muss. Dieses
Nebenkostenprivileg, das ja nicht
euer Privileg war, sondern das der Kabelanbieter,
das fällt jetzt ab
Juli weg. Und da die Vermieter
die Kosten dann nicht mehr weitergeben können,
werden wahrscheinlich sehr viele Kabel
in den VV-Verträge gekündigt.
Aber ganz wichtig, es geht um das Fernsehen.
Das hat nichts mit dem Internet über Kabel zu tun.
Diese Verträge sind davon nicht betroffen
und laufen einfach weiter.
Kleine persönliche Anekdote.
Muss man ja auch zusätzlich abschließen.
Ich habe Internet-Stelz über wo da vorn.
Ich habe aber zusätzlich noch einen Basic-Kabelanschluss.
Das ist nicht alles immer
dabei. Also man kann auch
Kabel und Internet haben, ohne Fernsehen
gucken zu können.
Ich habe da so eine Gigabit-Leitung
und früher war das so, dass
da Sperrfilter eingebaut waren,
damit so Kunden wie ich eben nur Internet
aus der Dose kriegen und kein Fernsehen.
Nun ist es aber so, dass bei Gigabit-Kabel-Internet
solche Sperrfilter nicht mehr funktionieren,
weil die Frequenzen für Fernsehen und Internet
so fröhlich durcheinander gehen.
Das heißt, habt ihr schnelles Kabel-Internet
zu Hause und zahlt nur dafür,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit extrem hoch,
dass ihr auch einfach
DVB-C aus der Dose bekommt.
Ach ja, ist das so?
Heißt, ich könnte meinen Basic-Kabelanschluss
abbestellen, mein Internet behalten
und ich könnte dann weitergucken?
Hmmm...
Ist das so?
Und tatsächlich, ich kriege über 100 Sender
viel mehr als bisher über
das kostenlose DVB-T2,
was ich vorher benutzt habe.
Und erstmals auch die ganzen privaten Sender.
Ist das so?
Aber nicht HD, das juckt mich nicht.
Die öffentlich-rechtlichen sind HD, das andere...
Mir ist es egal, ich gucke es ja eh nicht.
So, das gilt aber natürlich nur für Leute,
die Kabel-Internet haben.
Wenn ihr vorher über eure Miete Kabel-Fernsehen bezogen habt
und ihr keinen eigenen neuen
Vertrag abschließt, dann...
Warum habe ich das Fenster eigentlich klein?
...wird euer Kabel-Fernsehen ab Juli
wegfallen.
Und auch wenn ihr selbst gar kein Fernsehen mehr guckt
und euch das alles relativ egal ist,
wenn ihr die Menschen seid, die sich im Freundes-
und Bekanntenkreis um technische Probleme kümmern,
dann kommen da bestimmt einige
Anfragen auf euch zu in den nächsten Wochen.
Also, was jetzt tun, wenn der Mieter
mit Kabelvertrag wegfällt?
Da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Ihr könnt euren Fernsehempfang auf
digitales SAT-TV per Satellitenschlüssel,
also DVB-S, S2...
Das machst du halt auch nicht so easy.
Gerade in der Mietwohnung.
...oder digitales Antennen-Fernsehen, DVB-T2.
DVB-T ist so schrottig, ey.
Wenn ihr keine Antenne auf dem Dach bzw. auf dem Balkon habt
und die Vermieter euch das auch nicht erlauben,
dann fällt die SAT-Option schon mal weg.
Alternativ könnt ihr euch eine Zimmerantenne
für DVB-T2 holen.
Moderne Fernseher haben normalerweise
einen DVB-T2-Tuner integriert.
Ansonsten kosten die Geräte separat
etwa 30 Euro.
Die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender könnt ihr damit kostenlos empfangen.
Auch in HD.
Aber die privaten gar nicht.
Auch nicht in Standard-Auflösung.
Dafür braucht ihr ein Abo von Freenet.
Ja, das ist halt echt so ein Ding.
Da haben sie sich auch wieder so ein Ei gelegt.
Das ist echt...
Das ist komplettes Minenfeld.
Dieses, wie man wie wo gucken kann.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ich würde nie im Leben
ein Abo abschließen,
damit ich die privaten Sender in HD gucken kann.
Denn gleichzeitig
bekommst du da noch so nette Features wie,
dass du nicht aufnehmen kannst,
dass du in Aufnahmen, wenn sie möglich sind,
die Werbung nicht überspringen kannst.
Das ist da alles dabei.
Da ist es quasi DRM eingebaut.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Da ist DRM eingebaut,
dass ich nicht aufnehmen kann
und Aufnahmen da nicht überspringen kann.
Das ist komplett für den Arsch.
Das würde ich nie abschließen.
Das kostet 8 Euro pro Monat.
Ob ihr in eurer Wohnung überhaupt
von DVB-T2 abgedeckt seid...
Achso, wir sind noch bei DVB-T.
Ich rede jetzt auch gerade von Kabel.
Es ist komplett für den Arsch.
Bei DVB-T ist es wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Je ländlicher, desto schwieriger wird das.
Möglichkeit Nummer 2.
Ihr streamt das Fernsehen einfach
über eure Internetleitung.
Das ist vorausgesetzt.
Die Internetverbindung mit mindestens 16 Mbit pro Sekunde
ist der komfortabelste Weg.
Das sollte ja jeder haben.
Wir haben noch...
Sogar Merkel hat noch erzählt,
2018 50 Mbit für alle.
Also kann es nicht sein,
dass es heute Leute Anschlüsse haben
unter 50 Mbit.
Unmöglich.
Ich habe zwar damals auf Twitter
noch ein paar Jahre später darauf geantwortet,
dass es immer noch nicht der Fall ist,
aber das hat sie leider nicht interessiert,
dass ich auf Twitter geantwortet habe.
Also Fernseher, Tablet, PC
oder Smartphone.
Und ihr könnt euren Fernseher dann überall hinstellen
Es hat noch nicht mal den Regierungssprecher interessiert,
dass ich geantwortet habe auf Twitter.
Anzeige ist raus.
Nicht mehr auf den Antennenanschluss in der Wand achten
oder irgendwie hässlich Kabel verlegen.
Dafür gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten
und Anbieter.
Und da Kabel-TV-Verträge ab Juli
vermutlich zwischen 8 und 13 Euro kosten werden,
je nach Anbieter und Tarif,
könnt ihr damit sogar noch Geld sparen.
In unserem CT-Test haben wir uns
auf vier TV-Streaming-Anbieter fokussiert,
die ihr unabhängig
von eurem Internet-Anbieter benutzt.
Ich habe Satu und Vaipu
auch ausprobiert.
Vaipu-TV, HD plus IP
und Magenta-TV von der Telekom.
Die anderen Angebote, zum Beispiel
Vodafone und 1&1,
könnt ihr nur zusammen mit einem Internet-Account buchen.
Vorweg, die allergünstigste
Möglichkeit, um TV zu streamen,
ist die ARD- bzw. ZDF-Mediathek.
Da bekommt ihr kostenlos
ohne Anmeldung ARD, ZDF
und alle anderen...
Skispringen habe ich mit meinem Opa
früher auch immer viel geguckt.
Wenn ihr aber auch Privatsender wollt,
müsst ihr ein Abo abschließen,
auch beim Internet-Fernsehen.
Wenn ihr einen Fernseher von Panasonic habt,
dann könnte HD plus IP interessant sein.
Da bekommt ihr für 6 Euro im Monat
direkt am Fernseher Zugriff auf
alle öffentlich-rechtlichen und Privatsender in HD.
Direkt am Fernseher HD plus IP interessant sein.
Da bekommt ihr für 6 Euro im Monat
direkt am Fernseher Zugriff
auf alle öffentlich-rechtlichen
und Privatsender in HD.
Samsung und Amazon,
die ja auch Fire-TV-Geräte
in Kooperation mit Panasonic anbieten,
wollen bis Mitte des Jahres
den Dienst auch unterstützen.
Später im Jahr will HD plus
auch noch einen eigenen Stick auf den Markt bringen.
Die drei anderen Anbieter aus unserem Test
sind zwar etwas teurer als HD plus IP...
Du hast damit aber sicherlich
die gleichen Probleme.
Du musst entweder die offizielle App verwenden,
du kannst nicht richtig aufnehmen,
du hast nirgendeine Aufnahmebegrenzung...
Das ist bestimmt abfuck.
Es ist alles eklig.
...deutlich vielseitiger.
Die Preise sind aber je nach Anbieter und Funktion
ganz schön gestaffelt.
Doch, die öffentlich-rechtlichen,
da hast du IP-TV-Streams,
die kannst du starten mit VLC.
Zatu und Vaipu-TV bieten je
kostenlose Pakete mit den öffentlich-rechtlichen
Sendern in SD-Qualität an.
Bei Zatu bekommt ihr neben dem
kostenlosen Grundangebot diese drei Pakete.
Also je nachdem, ob ihr nur am TV
schauen wollt oder auch unterwegs
oder das TV-Programm aufzeichnen wollt.
Außerdem könnt ihr noch ausländische
und Pay-TV-Sender hinzubuchen.
Bei Vaipu-TV gibt es noch diese zwei
Pakete, die sich in der Aufnahmedauer
und dem Empfang von
Privatsendern in HD unterscheiden.
Auf Wunsch gibt es noch Netflix
oder DAZN gegen Aufpreis
dazu. Wenn man auch unterwegs
Privatsender schauen möchte...
Wait a minute, warum brauche ich Netflix?
Netflix ist ein eigener Service,
eine eigene App.
Was hat Netflix? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ist das für die Kack-Noobs,
die auf ihrem Fernsehen nur ihre
Channels durchswitchen können und
keine App starten?
What the fuck?
Da muss man nochmal 3 Euro drauflegen.
Der Dienst fragt deswegen, also wie Netflix,
nach einem Heim-Netzwerk.
Bei Magenta fängt das Angebot hier
bei 10 Euro an und kann je nach
zugebuchten Optionen bis zu
120 Euro im Monat kosten.
Je nach Laufzeit gibt es aber die ersten
Monate umsonst. Da ist dann aber auch
wirklich fast alles dabei, also
viele Streaming-Dienste und vor allem
Live-Sport. Das lässt sich
bei den anderen Anbietern auch dazu
buchen, allerdings bietet Magenta als
einziger Anbieter wirklich alle
Sportsender, die es in Deutschland gibt.
Das Gute, alle diese 3 TV-Streaming-Dienste
laufen auf vielen Smart-TVs
und Streaming-Sticks. Wir blenden
euch hier mal ein, wo was genau
funktioniert. Im Zweifelsfall reicht
da übrigens auch ein relativ alter
Fire-TV-Stick, den man... Ja, auf dem Shield-TV
läuft es. Ja, ja, Android-TV, ja.
Ach, guck mal, Sony würde hier nicht...
Auf Sony-Fernseher direkt würde es nicht laufen.
Ja, aber ich meine...
Android-TV passt ja.
Im Zweifelsfall reicht da übrigens auch ein relativ
alter Fire-... Wie sieht es eigentlich aus? Gibt es
nicht...
ein neues Shield-TV jetzt irgendwann mal?
Nö.
Das ist so alt, Mann! Das ist, keine
Ahnung, 5 Jahre alt oder so.
Also da muss man sagen, Update-mäßig
wird das nice versorgt. ...TV-Stick,
den man vielleicht noch in der Schublade liegen hat,
braucht man nämlich keinen neuen mit 4K-
Unterstützung, denn die Sender unterstützen
eh nur 1080p-Auflösung maximal.
Weil Pooh und die Telekom
haben außerdem eigene Streaming-Boxen
beziehungsweise Sticks im Angebot.
Was insgesamt etwas
nervt, ist die Sache mit den Lizenzen
bei manchen Privatsendern. Das führt dazu,
dass manche Sendungen gar nicht aufgenommen
werden und andere nicht dauerhaft...
Das ist das, was ich meine. Die haben halt
so ein DRM immer mit dabei und das ist
für mich, wie man so schön sagt, ein
No-Go. Aber so was,
von... Also, ich will
weder, dass die mir verbieten können,
Aufnahmen zu machen,
noch, dass wenn ich Aufnahmen
machen kann, darin spulen nicht möglich
ist und so ein Shit, Mann.
...gespeichert werden können.
Hier zum Beispiel, diese Aufnahme von ProSieben
ist... ...saff...
das... was?
Sa... Fates.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, aber Prime, ja,
aber Prime kannst du wiederum nicht aufnehmen.
...nur 60 Tage lang gültig,
und wird danach gelöscht. Diese
SpongeBob-Folge wird 180 Tage
lang gespeichert. Hä? An sich bieten zwar
alle Anbieter eine
Relive-Funktion an. Das heißt, ihr könnt
durch das Programm schalten und dann die laufende
Sendung einfach von vorne starten.
Das funktioniert aber wegen den Lizenzen
auch nicht bei allen Sendungen der Privatsender.
Vor allem Sender der ProSieben
Sat.1 Gruppe sind hier eingeschränkt.
Bei Sendern von RTL funktioniert zwar
die Relive-Funktion zuverlässig,
aber in unseren Tests konnten wir bei allen Privatsendern...
Es ist halt so lächerlich.
Es wird echt Zeit, dass
das ganze klassische Fernsehscheiße einfach stirbt.
...dann nicht immer vorspulen.
Wäre natürlich praktisch, um die Werbung zu überspringen.
Es gibt leider auch keine zuverlässigen
Angaben darüber, bei welchem Sender
was genau funktioniert. Also
ob zum Beispiel eine Aufnahme überhaupt möglich ist.
Das sieht man erst, wenn man auf die
Sendung geht und ein Aufnahmeknopf
angezeigt wird. Ja, oder eben nicht.
Der Fairness halber muss man dazu sagen, dass
diese ganze... So krasse Gängelung, für das, dass
das so viel Geld kostet. ...funktionen
an sich bei einem Kabel-TV-Anschluss
ja erstmal gar nicht zur Verfügung stehen
würden. Und wenn man das Geld in einen
Festplattenrekorder investiert, die Aufnahmen
hier zwar unbegrenzt gespeichert werden können,
aber erstmal eben nur auf dem Gerät selbst
Ja, Moment, Moment, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Du kannst es nicht speichern. Wenn du
HD, RTL oder so
oder HD Pro 7 gucken willst,
dann brauchst du ein
zertifiziertes Gerät mit der passenden
Smartcard drinne
und das ist nicht ein 0815 Videorekorder.
Kann das nicht.
Das funktioniert damit einfach nicht.
...wiedergegeben werden können,
weil die auf dem Gerät verschlüsselt werden.
Bei den TV-Streamern kann ich
am Smartphone auswählen, was aufgenommen
werden soll und das dann am Fernseher oder
am Tablet schauen. Also hat beides seine
Vor- und Nachteile. Was die Benutzeroberflächen
von den Anbietern angeht,
ist das ehrlicherweise Geschmackssache
und hängt auch davon ab, ob ihr gerade über
einen Apple-TV, Google-TV, Fire-TV-Stick
oder den Browser auf den Dienst
zugreift. Grundsätzlich haben wir uns
aber überall einigermaßen zurecht gefunden,
konnten komfortabel über das
EPG, Electronic
Program Guide, navigieren. Der
Zatu EPG ist
auch deutlich umfangreicher als bei
herkömmlichen TV-Anschlüssen.
Deine Capture Card kann nicht alles aufnehmen.
Du brauchst erst einmal, also
dass man mal sieht,
also ja, deine Capture Card kann alles aufnehmen,
was potenziell bei dir rauskommt,
aber wie kriegst du zum Beispiel
Pro 7 HD
bei dir
auf dem Rechner, dass du mit deiner Capture Card aufnehmen
kannst. Wie willst du das machen?
Du brauchst ein
zertifiziertes, also wenn man jetzt mal von
irgendwelchen illegalen CI-Karten-Dingern
absieht,
wobei das auch nicht
zwangsläufig bei allem aktuell
funktioniert. Du brauchst ein zertifiziertes
Gerät mit einer Karte drin, die
haben keinen HDMI-Ausgang.
Äh, wachse.
Die haben einen HDMI-Ausgang,
aber da kannst du keine Capture Card
dran anschließen, weil das Zeug macht,
wie heißt das, äh,
wie heißt das bei HDMI?
Handshake,
HDCP+, geht übrigens, ja.
Das ist echt so ein komplettes
Minenfeld, das traditionelle
Fernsehen, deswegen, ich lass wahrscheinlich so
für meine Mutter so, wie das ist.
Die kriegt jetzt Vodafone,
Basic Kabelanschluss,
die kann Öffentlich-Rechtliche damit gucken,
in HD und Privat und alles andere halt in SD
und fertig.
Bei Magenta TV geht das, Magenta TV
kannst du HD auf dem Rechner gucken, okay.
Ähm, aber du kannst wahrscheinlich
trotzdem nicht, also es gibt wahrscheinlich
keine gescheite Software, wo du jetzt
damit beispielsweise
Aufnahmen anfertigen kannst.
Oder gibt es mal ein TV Headend
Magenta TV Plugin?
Ja, meine kommt auch mit Apps und so
nicht klar. Die guckt ab und zu,
letztens hat sie irgendwas, weil sie
eine Sendung verpasst hat, mal
eine Serienfolge verpasst hat, mal irgendwas in der
Mediathek geguckt, aber die will weder
Netflix gucken, die will weder Amazon
Prime gucken, die will weder die Mediathek
Apps, es ist ja nicht so, als hätten
wir nicht genug Möglichkeiten, was
zu gucken. Irgendein Haken hat
das, dann kannst du es aber nicht am Fernseher gucken.
Ja, wenn es
ja, Cloud oder im Receiver,
genau, okay.
Und dann hast du wieder das gleiche Problem,
dass die dir dort auch, weil das zertifizierte
Geräte sind, dass sie dir dort auch verbieten
können, dass du was nicht aufnehmen
kannst, beziehungsweise, dass
du nicht
holen kannst in der Aufnahme zum Beispiel.
Das ist alles, dieses gesamte klassische
Fernsehkram, das ist alles, besteht nur aus
nur aus Gängelungen für User.
Den guten alten Teletext
oder auch Videotext. Jawoll!
Beste, Leute, beste!
Videotext.
Kennt wahrscheinlich heute keiner mehr,
aber Videotext.
Gibt es eigentlich,
gibt es Videotext online?
Moment, gibt es?
Ha!
Hier ist so immer wieder Buchstaben, mach mal
Ausrufezeichen 1, da gibt es eine Erklärung zu.
Videotext, jawoll!
Massive 200.
Das, das war, das war
das Internet für mich früher,
bevor es Internet gab.
Ich hab, ich hab den ganzen Tag
Videotext gebrowst, weil ich
das so Hackerman fand.
Also, wo ich wirklich klein war noch, also
irgendwie
6, 7 oder so.
Da hab ich immer Videotext aufgemacht, Videotext
angeguckt und hab gedacht, boah, ihr
ist das, das ist Wahnsinnsshit.
Wo das der Fernseher noch nicht
zwischengespeichert hat, genau. Wo du immer
warten musstest, bis das durchgelaufen
ist und das gefunden hat.
Ja, das ist schon
andere Welt gewesen.
Weiß nicht. Videotext
enjoyers. Okay.
Gibt's
leider bei keinem der Anbieter mehr.
Das macht mich persönlich sehr traurig.
Man kann aber zumindest ein Raspi umbauen,
um da auf Teletext zu generieren.
Einen CT-Artikel dazu habe ich... Unbedingt!
Die Bild- und Tonqualität war
bei allen anderen Anbietern
übrigens nahezu
gleich. Bei HD plus IP
bekommt ihr allerdings nur Stereo-Sound.
Die anderen drei Anbieter bieten auch
Dolby Digital 5.1. Das hängt dann
aber wieder vom Sender ab, ob der das überhaupt
unterstützt. Falls ihr euch jetzt
noch intensiver mit dem Thema TV-Streaming
befassen wollt, die ausführlichen
CT-Testberichte zu den Diensten und
kompatiblen Fernsehern bzw. Streaming
Sticks haben wir euch in der Beschreibung
verlinkt. Da findet ihr auch unsere drei
Angebote für drei Monate
Heise plus zum halben Preis, wenn ihr
uns unterstützen wollt. Ach ja, und
es gibt auch noch eine weitere Alternative
zu den TV-Streaming-Diensten. Ihr könnt
euch nämlich selber so einen Streaming-Dienst
bauen. Mit einem Home-Server und der
Linux-Open-Source-Software TV
Head-End könnt ihr jegliches
TV-Signal abgreifen und das
ins interne Netz streamen. Ja, so mache ich das.
Abgerufen werden kann das dann mit Smart-TV,
Raspi, Smartphone oder Tablet
oder auch direkt... Genau, so
mache ich das. In sowas wie Kodi,
und ihr könnt damit auch direkt
Aufnahmen machen, die dann lokal auf eurem
So läuft das bei mir.
Schon seit den
letzten Jahren und das funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Leider damit natürlich
auch keine privaten in HD
möglich, weil ich lasse mich nicht gängeln.
Aber zu Hause liegen.
Heißt, ihr habt auch den Vorteil, mehrere Geräte
benutzen zu können, ohne für jeden Fernseher
eine Kabelbuchse zu brauchen.
Falls euch das im Detail interessiert, dann
schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare. Vielleicht machen wir dann
dazu ein eigenes Video. Mein
Fazit. Grundsätzlich erstmal
eine gute Sache, dass ich mir als Mieter
selbst aussuchen kann, ob ich wirklich
einen Kabel-Fernsehanschluss brauche
und dafür bezahlen will. Es gibt ja
wirklich genug Alternativen und am Ende
bekommt man vielleicht sogar mehr Funktionen
für den gleichen Preis wie bisher.
Oder spart sogar Geld. Vor allem, wenn man
verschiedene Pakete zusammen bucht. Also
zum Beispiel Netflix, Disney Plus
und Live-TV in einem. Dafür
braucht man aber auch wirklich mindestens in einem
Tag, um das individuell am besten
geeignete Paket überhaupt zu finden.
Das ist halt wirklich super persönlich. Für manche
ist es das Killer-Feature, dass sie auch italienisches
oder türkisches Geld hin empfangen.
Anderen ist das egal. Dafür brauchen sie
den Sportsender, der die Eiskölle
Das ist, das ist eh die geilste
Sportart, ey.
Die hab ich, wenn es olympische
Spiele gibt, das ist, das ist,
das guck ich mir immer an. Ich find das so,
weiß ich, das hat so
ein gewisses...
Wisst ihr, das ist ein bisschen wie diese
Satisfying-Content-Videos.
Kennt ihr diese Videos, die, die
quasi im Titel stehen haben?
Most Satisfying Video. Und da guckst du dir das,
wie es dann, wie irgendwo was abgeschleift wird
oder irgendwo was gesägt wird
oder so. Das, das
mich interessiert die Sportart an sich null.
Aber ich find das super satisfying
zu sehen. Diese
Schrubber-Action und wie dann dieses
Ding daran slidet.
Dafür brauchen sie den Sportsender,
der die
die Eiskölle
Ach ja, wie mein aktuelles Setup ist.
Also, mein aktuelles Setup
ist, ich hab eine
VU Plus 4K
so ein Ding. Das hat nen
8-fach-Tuner, damit kannst du so viel empfangen
und dingsen, wie du willst.
Ich verwende dieses Ding
rein als
TV-Headend-Linux-Box.
Hier ist am HDMI
out, es ist nichts angeschlossen.
Da läuft noch nicht mal irgendein Frontend
drauf. Wenn ich das Ding
am Fernseher anschließen würde, da kommt außer
Konsole nix.
Da läuft TV-Headend drauf, auf der Kiste
hier.
Da steckt ne 2TB SSD drinnen.
Und die hängt im Netzwerk.
Die macht
quasi, äh,
8-fach-Tuner, Octa-Tuner
Empfang
mit TV-Headend.
Dann hab ich am Fernseher ein Shield-TV
und ich hab bei mir
hier, also
am Fernseher hab ich ein Shield-TV
auf dem Shield-TV ist
alles mögliche drauf, was man so braucht, Netflix,
Prime, äh, Kodi
und in Kodi ist
ein TV-Headend-Client installiert
und darüber kann
meine Mutter im Wohnzimmer
Fernsehen gucken.
Der TV-Headend-Client connectet
sich dann hier
übers Netzwerk zum TV-Headend-Server
da drauf und startet den Stream und guckt das.
Darüber kann man noch Aufnahmen
programmieren. Die Aufnahmen laufen
dann hier rauf und auf die SSD
dort. Also quasi
die, der Fernseher muss dazu nicht an sein
oder Shield-TV oder sonst was.
So, man kann dadurch, dass das Ganze
auf, hier auf dem
TV-Headend-Server liegt,
kann man ohne Probleme die Aufnahmen
auch vom Tablet gucken oder vom
Smartphone gucken oder Fernsehen gucken vom Tablet
und vom Smartphone, also alles was da im Netzwerk
ist oder ich hier bei mir
mit Kodi und dem TV-Headend-Client
im, unter Linux
oder unter Windows, ich kann quasi im ganzen Netzwerk
Fernsehen gucken damit.
Das ist mein Setup. Aber ich benutze
das so gut wie nie. Das einzige
was ich damit echt gucke ist mal irgendein
Radrennen oder sowas.
Wenn es denn was gibt.
Tuner? Nein, nicht. Kabel? Also das kann Satellit
und Fernseher, also es ist DVB-C.
Das ist Kabel-Fernseher
bei mir. Es könnte aber
auch
Fernseh-Satelliten-Fernseher sein. Es würde
genauso funktionieren.
Was kann der ER-Sensor? Wahrscheinlich eine
Fernbedienung anschließen.
Wahrscheinlich dann
drüber
Input.
Die Kiste ist
super weird champ
aufzusetzen, weil
die Firmware mit der das Ding ausgeliefert
wird, ist kompletter Schrott.
Geht das Ding auch
in der Schweiz, wenn ihr DVB-C oder
DVB-S habt, geht das.
Die Firmware die da mitkommt ist kompletter
Schrott. Die Firmware da drauf ist
ausgelegt als Setup-Box.
Also als
GUI mit
also klassischer Fernseh-GUI-Oberfläche
ist das.
Das sieht dann aus wie
das sieht dann wirklich auf dem Fernseh aus wie 1995.
Man sieht es jetzt nicht so genau.
Und das ist halt kompletter Schrott
dafür verwendet. Ja guck hier.
Das sieht aus wie 1995 dann auf
dem Fernseh. Mit dieser
Firmware wird das Ding halt ausgeliefert. Das ist gedacht
als Receiver-Setup-Box
für den Fernseh.
So.
Die Firmware die standardmäßig drauf ist
ist komplett useless Schrott
für das was ich verwenden will.
Das erste was ich gemacht habe ist
diese
Community-Edition von dieser
VU-Plus-Firmware drauf zu flashen
ist aber auch Schrott, weil
das verwendet das offizielle
Linux-Image von denen mit ein paar Zusatzdingern.
Es ist ein hoffnungslos
uralter
outdated Kernel auf dem nichts
läuft. Der einzige Vorteil ist
dass die proprietären
Tunertreiber dort am besten
funktionieren.
So was ich da drauf laufen habe auf der Box
ist
Open
ATV heißt das ganze glaube
ich.
Open ATV?
Nee.
Download Open ATV.
Heißt das Open ATV?
Open VTI? Nee.
VTI ist das
outdated Zeug.
Ich glaube ich habe
Open ATV drauf laufen.
Ja Open ATV Images.
Nee.
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr.
Das funktioniert nicht super
weil es so ein outdated uralt Kernel hat
dass du kein TV-Header drauf kriegst.
Ähm.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es das ist.
Ich bilde mir ein das ist es.
Zumindest das hat zwar auch ein
GUI aber drauf geschissen.
Ich glaube
das ist es.
Zumindest ich habe das GUI
komplett abgeschaltet weil
ich verwende ja den HDMI Ausgang hiervon gar nicht.
Das ist für mich im Prinzip eine Linux Box
wo ich per SSH drauf komme mit einem Package Manager
und da habe
ich TV-Headern drauf installiert.
TV-Headern mit den passenden
Tunertreibern kann
quasi jetzt als
ganz normaler TV-Headern Server fungieren.
Und dementsprechend
hast du auch die Möglichkeit
auf TV-Headern von allen unterstützten Clients
zuzugreifen.
Das ist einfach die mit Abstand verbreitetste
TV über Netzwerk-Guck-Lösung unter Linux.
Oder nicht unter Linux.
Generell würde ich sagen.
TV-Headern.
Wie gesagt gibt es Clients für Tablets
für Smartphones, für Android TV, für alles.
Und deswegen
funktioniert das ganz gut.
Bei VTi Plus gibt es ein eigenes
Kodi-Add-On. Das ist aber Schrott.
Also die einzige
sinnvoll benutzbare
Möglichkeit hierfür
und die funktioniert auch wirklich sehr gut
ist für mich gewesen
Custom Firmware drauf flashen
und zwar ich bilde mir ein
das war OpenATV, ist schon eine Weile her
TV-Headern drauf packen
und gut ist.
Und dann nie wieder anfassen.
Das Ding läuft jetzt seit
bestimmt einem Jahr
durchgängig ohne jegliche Probleme.
Das ist so lange her, dass ich
mein Passwort nicht mal mehr weiß,
wenn ich mich jetzt drauf einloggen müsste.
Ich glaube ich habe es irgendwo
Key-Safe
Passwort-Safe irgendwo gespeichert.
Wahrscheinlich ist das
Root-Passwort 123456
gehe ich auch von aus.
Ja, denke ich mir auch.
Und das ist
die beste Kombi, die ich gefunden habe bisher.
Klassisches
Fernseher, Kabelfernseher
hier ins Netzwerk zu bringen.
Leider gehen keine
Datensender in HD, weil
dafür müsstest du Glück
haben, dass es überhaupt geht und
irgendwelche komischen Smartcard
Emulations
Geschiss machen, wo ich keinen Bock drauf
habe, denn Stress ist es mir nicht wert.
Zumal ich das gar nicht gucke
und meine Mutter
so jemand ist, der den Unterschied
zwischen SD und HD noch nicht mal
richtig erkennt.
Für mich ist es ja
unverständlich.
Für mich ist es ja unverständlich, aber
es gibt ja Leute, die erkennen
den Unterschied
zwischen 30 und 60
oder 120
FPS nicht.
Für die sagen sie, wieso sieht doch alles gleich aus.
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Es gibt auch Leute, die erkennen den Unterschied nicht
zwischen Paarlauflösung und 720p.
Die sehen das einfach nicht.
Die haben da keinen Blick mehr.
Für mich, ohne Scheiß, ich sehe das
wie würde man sagen,
ich kann das
3 Meter gegen den Wind, aber das macht beim
Sehen keinen Sinn.
Ich sehe, ich gucke da eine halbe
Sekunde hin und ich sehe, es ruckelt.
Es ist nur 30 FPS.
Ich sehe, okay, das ist aber
hier und da pixelig oder hier
Kompressionsartefakte und da ist die
Bitrate zu niedrig und da ist zu wenig
FPS, zu geringe Bitrate,
zu geringe Auflösung. Ich sehe das sofort.
Die sieht das nicht.
Die kann das nicht erkennen.
Und wenn man es dir direkt nebeneinander
zeigt, dann sagt sie zwar so,
ja, das sieht man, aber ich glaube, das sagt die einfach nur,
um mich zu beruhigen.
Die sieht das gar nicht wirklich.
Ja, aber das musst du erstmal hinbasteln.
Da brauchst du von Vodafone die passende
Karte, dann brauchst du die passende
Software dafür,
die diese CI-Karte
dann ordentlich
der CI-Karte vorgaukelt.
Sie würde in einem offiziellen
Receiver sitzen.
Also das ist ziemlich konfigurationsintensiv,
bis das wirklich funktioniert.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Und werde ich auch nicht machen.
Ja,
sagt Jurassic Park, ob das wirklich so war,
man weiß es nicht.
Könnte man
statt dem VO Plus
auch einfach einen Mini-PC mit USB-TV
tunern nehmen? Selbstverständlich, kannst du das machen.
Hatte ich früher auch. Ich hatte davor
ein Odroid HC2
im Wohnzimmer stehen.
Dieses Teil hatte ich davor
im Wohnzimmer stehen. Ey, das sieht jetzt ein bisschen blöd aus.
Das kann man schön in die Ecke packen.
Das ist im Prinzip ein Singleboard-Computer.
Quasi ein bisschen wie der Raspberry Pi.
Nur nicht so bekannt.
Und auch nicht so gut supportet.
Das ist ein Singleboard-Computer mit einem SATA-Anschluss.
Da konntest du die Festplatte reinmachen.
So ein Ding hatte ich im Wohnzimmer stehen.
Allerdings ohne dieses hässliche Gehäuse.
Und ich hatte die
kleine Bauweise
wo man hier
so sah das bei mir ungefähr aus.
Wie das mit der SSD da unten aussah.
Und da hatte ich das auch.
Da hatte ich per USB
ein Stick
dran.
Ein USB Dual-Tuner
Stick.
Das Ding hat genau ein USB-Anschluss.
Ja.
Das so ein Ding hatte ich davor.
Dann habe ich das
abgelöst.
Ich weiß nicht mehr warum.
Das hat irgendwelche Probleme gemacht.
Ich kann euch nicht
mal genau sagen, warum ich das abgelöst habe.
Danach habe ich versucht abzulösen.
Durch den Raspberry Pi.
Also quasi Raspberry Pi mit
dem USB-Tuner und
der USB-SSD.
Da hatte ich Riesenprobleme.
Und zwar der Raspberry Pi
USB-Port hat
zu wenig Strom geliefert.
Für SSD plus Tuner Stick.
Und das lief dann
immer so, dass der Raspberry Pi
I.O. Fehler auf der SSD hatte.
Weil die nicht genug mit Strom versorgt werden kann.
Oder der Stick abgekackt ist.
Ich habe es dann probiert
mit einem
USB-Hub.
Wo man extra noch Strom dran macht.
Aber es hat nur Probleme gemacht.
Da war das Setup hier deutlich problemloser.
Also da sag ich nur, da musst du dran denken.
Das sind so Dinge, die
einem am Anfang gar nicht einfallen.
Du kannst dann ein Mini-PC hinstellen
mit USB-TV.
Wenn es ein wirklicher Mini-PC ist, dann ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann hast du auch keine Stromversorgungsprobleme.
Weil das ist nicht so
schwachbrüstig wie der Raspberry Pi.
Und du musst ja auch die SSD
quasi nicht über den gleichen USB-Port betreiben.
Intern ist
beim Raspberry Pi das ja alles nur beschränkt.
Für alle USB-Ports.
Also wenn du einen Mini-PC hinstellst.
Du packst da einen TV-Tuner rein.
Entweder per USB.
Oder mit einer
PC Express Karte und einer SSD.
Ist das auch super
super Lösung.
Musst du aber bedenken.
Dass du einen
TV-Tuner brauchst.
Der
mehr als eine Sache
gleichzeitig entfangen kann.
Sonst hast du nämlich das Problem.
Dass du
nichts gucken
und aufnehmen kannst gleichzeitig.
Oder dass du, wenn du mehrere Leute
im Netzwerk hast, die was gucken müssen,
dass dann die Aufnahme nicht geht.
Also wenn du safe sein möchtest.
Brauchst du nicht nur
einen Dual-Tuner, sondern einen Quad-Tuner.
Mit einem Quad-Tuner
bist du bei DVB-C
auf der komplett
sicheren Seite.
Weil
ich krieg's grad nicht so
Ne, bei SAT
bin ich mir grad nicht sicher. Ist schon eine Weile her, wo ich mich
damit beschäftigt hab. Aber ich glaub
ein Quad-Tuner reicht aus, dass du alles
gucken kannst. Weil
die Tuner können immer nur
ne bestimmte
Frequenz
und ne bestimmte Polarisierung.
Wobei ich glaub das ist bei SAT so.
Ja. Und
zumindest wenn du 4 Tuner
hast, hast du alle Möglichkeiten abgedeckt.
Und kannst so viel aufnehmen und so viel gleichzeitig gucken
wie du willst. Weil selbst in laufender
Tuner das andere mitempfangen kann, weil es
die gleiche Frequenz und gleiche Polarisierung
oder wie auch immer ist.
Quad-Tuner reicht.
Ja. Quad-Tuner.
Dann hast du keine Probleme mehr. Dual-Tuner tut's auch.
Aber du kannst es machen.
Mini-PC, Mini-PC und
USB-C.
Du brauchst halt nen guten USB-Stick
oder ne gute TV-Karte,
die unter Linux supported wird. Aber ich geh mal davon aus,
dass du es mit Linux machen willst.
Weil TV-Head-End. Musst du dich halt vorher schlau machen,
welche es gibt. Und ich kann dir ehrlich sagen,
USB-Tuner
DVB-C USB-Tuner
für Linux mit gescheiter
Firmware ist sehr rar.
Das ist alles irgendwie Schrott.
Deswegen hab ich mich ja
letztendlich auch für die VO Plus mit Custom-
Firmware entschieden.
Weil das für mich die sinnvollste
Kombination war.
Aber das geht. Musst dich nur schlau machen,
was du für einen USB-Stick kaufst.
Also ich hatte den hier.
WinTV Dual-Tuner.
Dieses Teil hatte ich.
Und das lief unter Linux
ganz okay.
Allerdings
muss man, damit das wirklich
rund läuft, also out of the box
läuft es nicht. Du musst dir
Binary Plop Package laden
und das
richtige Verzeichnis kopieren unter Linux.
Dann geht das.
Und ich weiß nicht, was es für einen...
Am besten ist
wahrscheinlich, du kaufst dir eine Quad-Tuner
Karte, wenn du genug Platz
in dem Mini-PC hast. Dann hast du
wirklich das Beste aus allen Welten.
Wenn du eine gute, falls es sowas gibt,
eine gute Quad-Tuner Karte
mit Linux-Treibern, so das
wirst du wahrscheinlich gut funktionieren.
Egal.
Wie gesagt, klassische Fernsehtechnik
ist übelst der
krasseste Abfuck,
wenn man sich damit im Detail beschäftigt.
Ich bin froh, dass ich
nichts benutze an klassischem Fernsehen
und meine Mutter sich
mit dem Minimal-Programm
aus öffentlich-rechtlichen
und privaten
in SD zufrieden gibt.
Ja. Wir haben das Video übrigens immer noch nicht fertig
geguckt.
Vor den letzten 5 Minuten.
Das Gute, die meisten
Anbieter geben euch einen kostenlosen
WM-Übertrag.
Ist das Knossi?
Nee, oder?
Das sieht aber irgendwie ähnlich aus.
Die meisten Anbieter geben euch einen kostenlosen
Probe-Monat. Da könnt ihr dann selbst in Ruhe ausprobieren,
ob das für euch oder die Person,
für die ihr den Anschluss einrichtet, funktioniert.
Und zwar am besten, bevor der
Kabel-TV-Anschluss gekündigt wird.
Was vor allem meinen Kollegen Lukas nervt,
ist der Zeitversatz beim
TV-Streaming übers Internet.
Weil der halt gerne Fußball guckt und seine Nachfahren
die...
Vorletzte WM
oder sowas.
Nee, das muss schon...
Wann ist WM? Dieses Jahr?
Nee, dieses Jahr ist EM.
Wann war letzte
WM?
WM.
Wikipedia.
Okay.
2022.
Hier, 2010.
2010 muss das gewesen sein.
Weil 2013 bin ich ja umgezogen.
In der alten
Wohnung. Das war dann
wahrscheinlich die WM 2010.
Das war so
weird zu beobachten.
Dort, wir haben
geguckt über
DVB-T damals.
DVB-T.
Andere Leute haben geguckt
über DVB-T.
Manche über SAT.
Manche schon
übers Internet.
Und du hast
seriously, wenn
irgendwo was passiert ist,
du hast das randomized
gehört, wo gejubelt wurde.
Das war ganz
merkwürdig. Du hast
bei dir... DVB-T ist das langsamste
überhaupt gewesen.
Du hast den schon losrennen sehen
bei dir. Und du hast dann
irgendwo Jubels in der Straße.
Das heißt, du wusstest,
der, der jetzt losrennt,
in den nächsten 20
Sekunden passiert jetzt was.
Das war richtig kacke.
Und du hast...
Du konntest quasi anhand
der Jubel
Latency feststellen,
wer mit welcher Technik
geguckt hat.
Ja, SAT ist auch am schnellsten.
Habe ich tatsächlich auch gehört.
Ich persönlich hätte jetzt eigentlich
erwartet, dass
Internet Streaming
am schnellsten ist.
Aber ich habe mal ein paar
Vergleiche gesehen, da war Internet Streaming
glaube ich sogar
am langsamsten.
Übrigens, das schnellste ist tatsächlich
Radio. Klassisches analoges Radio.
Ist Latency...
Ist das most latency free
Infomedium.
Für sowas. Falls sich
irgendjemand mit Radio zufrieden gibt.
Also, analoges
Radio.
Wenn ihr noch ein bisschen schneller
wissen wollt, wenn irgendwo einer ein Tor geschossen hat.
Internet ist immer am
langsamsten wegen dem Buffer.
Das ist jetzt aber mal super allgemein ausgedrückt.
Wie gesagt,
ich kann innerhalb
von 50
Millisekunden von hier in China sein.
Und wir reden hier von
Sekundenlatency.
Und nicht irgendwie Millisekundenbereich.
Also, das ist mit
Streaming sollte das durchaus möglich
sein. Ich könnte mir
aber vorstellen, dass der Workflow
einfach nicht
dahingehend
optimiert ist.
So nach dem Motto, das geht erstmal
durch die ganze Infrastruktur
durch. Wird alles
processed. Und ganz
am Ende geht das Signal dann noch
ähm
nochmal vielleicht durch einen Encoder.
Und dann
zu irgendwelchen Streaming Anbietern.
Also, ich glaube, das ist ein
organisatorisches Problem, kein technisches Problem.
Dass die Internet
Streams so lahm sind.
Radiosendungen, wo der Typ im Stadion
sitzt, meine ich jetzt.
Also, Latency
ist im analogen
Radio echt am besten.
Muted.
Ja. Aber
so sieht es aus. Und das ist echt
kompletter Abfuck, die analoge
äh nicht analoge, klassische so TV
Technik.
Ich mach da einen großen Bogen rum.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was
das ist. Hm. So ein Buffer
ist jetzt nicht zwangsläufig
äh, ein großes, ein großes Delay.
Also, selbst
selbst, du, ja.
Ich war heute Morgen schon rennen.
Also selbst, wenn du ein Buffer hast
von, also ein klassischer Buffer, ja.
I-O Buffer.
Das sind 4K zum Beispiel.
Ja, 4K bei einem Videostream, das ist
quasi nahezu Echtzeit. Und das ist.
Nicht spürbar. Ähm,
was du meinst ist, das Buffert immer
so 10 Sekunden,
dass es im Zweifelsfall
wenn mal keine Daten reinkommen, weiterläuft
und dann wieder aufholt und sowas.
Das kommt ein bisschen auf die, auf die, auf die
Übertragungstechnik an. Dass es relativ
Latency-Free geht,
übers Netzwerk Video zu übertragen,
siehst du erstens im professionellen
Umfeld, sowohl
in Audio-Studios als auch in Video-Studios, da ist ja
viel Equipment auch nur noch über,
Anführungszeichen, nur noch über Netzwerk,
verbunden. Und du siehst es bei
handelsüblichen Sachen,
die beispielsweise über WebRTC
gehen. WebRTC,
also,
Teams geht zum Beispiel über WebRTC,
wobei Teams teilweise
auch laggt, aber das liegt
weniger an WebRTC, eher an
der Verbindung der beteiligten
Personen, würde ich mal behaupten.
WebRTC ist nahezu Latency-Free.
Wenn du ein Kamerabild per WebRTC
überträgst, hat das
150 Millisekunden
Delay, also
etwas
fühlbar, aber nicht auffällig.
Also so wenig Delay, dass wenn du
in die Kamera sprichst, dass es den
Leuten gar nicht wirklich auffällt, dass sich dein
Mund und das Sound ein bisschen
nicht synchron sind.
Wenn du es
unterschiedlich aufnimmst. Ja, wenn du es vorher natürlich syncst
und dann encodest, alles gut.
Moment, das ist was anderes, was
du jetzt hier sagst.
Das ist das Encoding. Das ist der
Intervall zwischen iFrames
und
Oh, ich hab vergessen, wie der Kram heißt.
iFrames
Also
im Prinzip, ich weiß
nicht mehr, wie das heißt. Das, was du meinst,
ist der Intervall zwischen
Vollbildern, vollen
encodenden Bildern plus Diffs.
Videocodecs machen es ja so,
die übertragen ein
komplettes Bild, komprimiert,
ein komplettes Bild und die nächsten,
äh,
Bilder werden quasi nur als
Diff übertragen zum letzten
vollen Bild. Damit
sparst du dir halt ziemlich viel.
Und das ist das, was du meinst,
wenn es in 4 Blöcken encoded wird.
In 4 Sekunden Blöcken.
Und deswegen
kann das manchmal sein, dass
wenn du jetzt einen Kamerastream aufmachst
und der
Kamerastream gerade, sag mal du machst
einen RTSP-Stream auf zu einer Kamera
und
die Kamera gerade nicht bei einem I-Frame ist,
dass du dann erstmal
3 Sekunden warten musst, bis der erste
I-Frame kommt. Ich glaube es heißt
I-Frame. Ja, I-Frame.
Also stellt euch vor, ihr habt einen Kamerastream,
die Kamera überträgt gerade Videomaterial
allerdings nur als Diff
zum letzten vollen Bild.
Dann musst du quasi 3 Sekunden warten,
bis du
das nächste, bis du das nächste
volle Bild bekommst. Das heißt aber nicht,
dass du eine Verzögerung hast. Das heißt
nur, dass du 3 Sekunden, nachdem du
den Feed eingeschaltet hast,
erst was siehst. Weil du kannst
erst anzeigen, ab dem du das erste Mal
ein volles Bild... Das heißt nicht,
dass dein Video-Feed 3 Sekunden
verzögert ist. Das heißt, du siehst erst
3 Sekunden, nachdem du die Wiedergabe gestartet hast.
Ja, es
gibt viele Video-Clients und so und VLC
macht es scheinbar auch. Die buffern das
Ganze noch ein bisschen. Das ist aber nicht
zwangsläufig notwendig. Also man kann
zum Beispiel mit FFmpeg
kann man die Blogseite
einstellen und die
Buffer-Size und alles. Wenn man das ganz
ganz klein stellt, auf irgendwie nur 4K
oder so, halt so klein einstellt,
dass es nicht ruckelt, also
nicht Aussätze hat,
dann bist du auch mit einem ganz
normalen Stream von einer Videokamera,
es sei denn, die Kamera
hat irgendwie einen Delay am Start,
die buffert noch mal
groß, hast du ein relativ
relativ latencyfreies Bild.
Mit relativ latencyfrei meine ich,
dass du halt nicht
es offensichtlich siehst, wenn du
beispielsweise, wenn du mal in die Kamera
winkst, dass es dir nicht
dass die Diskrepanz zwischen
dem, was du mit deinen Augen siehst und das, was du
quasi auf deinem
Display über den Feed siehst, so
krass abweicht, dass du sagen wirst, oh
das ist jetzt nicht mehr, kann man sich
ja nicht geben. Oder auch wenn du
jemanden aufnimmst, der redet und
du nimmst das Audio
parallel auf und
dann siehst du zwar vielleicht minimal, dass es
verzögert ist, aber es ist, sag mal, es ist
unter einer halben Sekunde, die Verzögerung.
Das kriegst du mit vielen Kameras hin,
wenn du die Wiedergabe
ordentlich einstellst.
Wie gesagt, es sei denn, die Kameras machen
das selbst. Also, weder die
Verzögerung beim Abspielen, noch
dass es in vier Blöcken encoded wird,
sorgt wirklich für Latency.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
an welcher Stelle wie viel gebuffert wird.
Aber wenn man das runterstellt, ich hab ganz billige
China-Chinesen Reolink
Kameras hier am Start.
Und wenn ich die, wenn ich dort per RTSP
mit streame,
beispielsweise per FFmpeg und alle Buffers
runtergestellt hab, ist das
würde ich sagen,
unter 100 Millisekunden, das
Delay. Und das kommt
halt von, ja, Encoding
und Netzwerkübertragung
letztendlich.
Crypto heute rot, ist
das so? Oh, es fällt
Bitcoin jetzt wieder, es ging in den letzten Tagen
ging es noch richtig stonksmäßig ab.
Aber Leute, ich muss jetzt was essen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Wir hören uns später oder morgen oder die Tage.
Ich weiß, ich hab ein bisschen wenig gestreamt in letzter Zeit.
Ich hab auch ein bisschen wenig Videos gemacht.
Ist einfach alles zur Zeit
hat der Tag, hat nur 24 Stunden.
Ja. Ich geh arbeiten.
Ich mach wieder
jetzt, weil schöner Wetter ist, geh ich mal Fahrrad fahren.
Bisschen mehr rennen. Ich will auch
privat noch ein bisschen was spielen und machen.
Wenn ich da bin, bin ich wieder da.
Aber es wird nicht allzu lange dauern.
Bis denn, Leute. Wir hören uns. Macht's gut. See you.